Hello everybody!
Hello...
Wait, are you still on your phone?
I'm still on your phone!
I thought you were gonna get out your...
Guys, I was listening to Gumi chopping her artichokes.
And now her stomach hurts because she ate too many artichokes.
New artichokes.
I had an artichoke cam while we were... I was waiting.
Okay, guys, a several disargument with both me, guys.
Is artichoke a food or a side dish?
A garnish?
Artichokes are fucking...
A dressing.
I don't think artichoke is a food.
You don't just eat...
You don't just eat a garnishing.
You don't just eat a artichoke.
You have other things with the artichoke.
She just ate an artichoke for like dinner last night.
She like...
What do you...
She just ate... I was like, you just ate an artichoke?
And she's like, yeah, I just ate an artichoke.
It's like her favorite thing.
I was like, that's not food.
That's not...
That's not food.
You can't just eat an artichoke.
And then we had like a debate about whether or not vegetables are considered food.
Sorry for all the vegetarians and vegans out there.
I'm telling you.
Artichoke is...
Do you know what a garnish or a dressing is?
Yes, I know what it is.
But like artichoke is like...
It's just an artichoke.
You tell me what your definition of a garnish and or a dressing is.
It's like a side thing.
Like, you know, you put it on top of real food.
You're pissing me off.
What do you mean a side thing?
You don't just eat artichoke.
You don't just order...
Okay, do you go to a restaurant and just order one artichoke?
Sometimes.
Really?
Yeah, is it a main dish or a side dish?
It's a side dish, but...
Hold on.
I got my artichokes from Costco and they're really big.
That's not a restaurant!
What are you saying?
I was like, do you go to a restaurant and like...
I said yes!
Then you went, I go to Costco.
I was telling you that...
I went to Costco and got these really big artichokes.
That's why it's not just a side dish to me.
Yeah, but you chop off the big artichoke and then make it into small things.
So you can just have...
You don't just eat an artichoke as a main dish.
You just don't.
What do you mean chop up the artichoke?
Do you know how to eat an artichoke?
Yeah, you chop... I literally saw you...
You were like live streaming yourself chopping artichokes for me.
What the fuck do you mean?
I was cutting the top off!
You have to cut the top of the leaves off!
It's... It's an artichoke.
You can't just eat an artichoke.
You can't.
It's impossible!
What do you mean it's impossible?
By the way, I never got your in line.
What the fuck do you mean?
Are you just too busy chopping artichokes?
I hate chopping artichokes.
Okay, let me invite you again.
I invited you.
I'm still not getting it.
Wait, what?
Is it because I didn't click play on mine first?
Yeah, I think you...
No!
Wait, what?
Wait, no, that's not right.
Okay.
You got it?
Nope.
My sound guy was like...
Gumi's volume is good despite her passion for artichoke.
I need to talk to your sound guy.
Let him do the group chat.
Alright, I'm gonna make a poll.
I'm gonna make a poll.
Is artichokes...
Are artichokes a mini dish?
Guys, I need you guys to actually vote with your heart.
And don't vote because you...
You wanna fuck with me.
Like...
What do you mean?
I mean they always vote with their heart.
No, no, no, no.
I need them to vote with their heart.
Like, would you eat...
I voted with my heart.
Okay.
Would you eat an artichoke as your main dish?
Like, okay.
Vegetarian.
Vegan.
Fried.
Vegetarians don't just eat artichokes.
They eat salads.
They can have salads and like other shit.
They don't just be like...
Halo stare.
I can eat salads and stuff.
I just want an artichoke.
They don't say that.
I might not be a vegetarian, but I won't be like...
Hello, can I just have an artichoke for dinner?
Like, I would not say that.
It is like a side and an appetizer.
Exactly.
Look, 70% people agree with me that it's not a main dish.
I never said it was a main dish.
No, no, no.
This is our entire argument.
I don't eat it for dinner.
This was our entire argument.
What did you say?
I was like...
Do you see the artichoke?
No.
The argument was that you called it a dressing or a garnish.
No, I said dressing, garnish, side.
I said dressing, garnish, side.
It can't be all three.
It cannot be all three.
No, I said dressing, garnish, or side.
And you were like...
You were like, no, I just eat the artichoke.
I was like, that is not...
You can't do that.
You can't just eat an artichoke as a main dish.
Also, I sent you another invite.
I can't do that.
I just sent you another invite.
I'm not getting it.
Then you are what's wrong with society.
I sent you another invite.
I said it was my main dish.
Not anyone's main dish.
But my main dish.
So you are a freak then.
But you know what?
I'll even send you a photo of my artichoke from last night.
Because I was...
I was...
I was eating that shit.
Then you got a stomach ache after.
You were like, oh, I think I got a tummy hurt because it was from the artichoke.
Yeah.
Who said that?
No.
It's because I ate two artichokes yesterday.
Oh my god.
A whole two?
I wonder...
You can't just get a stomach ache because you...
Oh my god.
It's like, yeah, I had two eggs today.
That's why my tummy hurt.
Like, what?
What is that logic?
No, I'm saying that logic exists because of the fiber.
The fiber.
It's gonna make me need a poo.
Holy shit.
Those are giant artichokes.
I told you.
What the fuck?
Look at the size of comparison.
What?
That...
You're freaking...
What?
She sent me a picture of her artichoke dish.
You can just stream.
Go ahead.
I don't care.
And I was like, what the fuck is this?
What the fuck is a giant artichoke?
What kind of...
What the fuck?
Were they grown in the...
Were they grown in the lab or some shit?
What is this fucking artichoke that I'm looking at?
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna try not to show Gumi's thighs.
Did I have to take the photo like that?
Because my keyboard was messed up.
Whoops, I accidentally...
I accidentally...
Okay, I sized myself bigger just for comparison with the artichoke.
Which...
It was sort of an accident, but...
What do you mean by comparison?
Like, look...
Oh my god.
That's a giant ass artichoke.
No wonder your tummy hurt.
Holy fuck.
Also, give me a second.
I need to resize myself.
I'm way too close to the screen.
What the fuck is that?
That's an artichoke.
That's...
What?
Oh, dang.
What the fuck is that?
It's an artichoke.
Look, if people in my chat are like, what the fuck is that?
Then...
That's not...
This is not a me issue.
Okay, I'm just saying those are giant artichokes.
This is true.
And that's why it was a main dish to me because it was so huge.
But don't...
Why don't you just cut it up?
Why would I cut it up?
It doesn't change the way you eat it.
Someone was like, that thing belongs to the wilderness.
Not the table.
That looks like a dead space baby, genetically modified artichoke.
No, do you know what?
You're right, because they are fucking huge and my mom bought me them because she's like, look how big these artichokes are, and I know you love artichokes.
Someone was like, you're supposed to take it apart.
What the fuck?
Well you're not even eating artichokes, right?
No, you haven't!
That's what I've been saying!
Because you called it a garnish dude.
Garnish is like putting like tiny parsley on top.
Well, like, yeah, I mean you can still put that on top.
It's just gonna be the whole thing.
Bro, accept my fucking if, but I said you like three.
I'm telling you it's not working!
Restart your game!
I did!
Oh wait, no I didn't.
I know you didn't because you were too busy talking about my artichokes!
Look, it's not... look that... it was important.
It was a very important conversation.
You wouldn't understand.
You're out here fucking stuffing yourself with artichokes.
Can we talk about our wording?
Can we talk about how we phrase things?
Yeah, I'm not gonna change my wording.
What are you talking about?
What the fuck?
I'm not gonna change.
Okay, alright, let me invite you again.
Alright, play online.
I'm connecting.
Okay, I'm literally staring at the game.
I'm staring at it.
Alright, I sent you an invite.
I got it!
See, it wasn't my fault.
You literally just restarted.
No, no, no.
Because you restarted too, right?
Alright, so we'll never know whose fault it is.
I didn't restart.
Because we'll never know.
No, you restarted, right?
You restarted.
We'll never know whose fault it is, guys.
We'll never know.
Alright, this is me.
We're getting a divorce.
I don't know if you guys noticed, but we're...
Guys, I don't know if you guys noticed, but...
We might be getting a divorce.
We might be.
Gumi, are you alive?
Gumi?
Oh, I think she's dead.
Guys...
Sorry, I was talking about my artichoke.
You're choking on your artichoke.
I told you to cut up the artichoke!
That's not how you eat it.
Yes, you can!
Just cut it up!
You're fucking choking!
I wasn't choking!
I was getting my controller!
You just said you were choking on an artichoke!
You're making shit up.
No, no, no.
I'm pretty sure... Chat...
Chat, did I hear it correctly?
She said she was choking on the artichoke.
She has so many toys.
Alright, what were we supposed to do here?
Oh, we had the car!
Alright, I called dibs on the car.
Don't do it!
You kept crashing last time!
No, no, it's because you were driving.
I'm a better driver.
It's time for a new friend.
Because I'm the wife.
She did!
It's not because of whatever you are.
I don't know why.
It's just that you as a person...
With your personality, it's just a worse driver.
Nothing else.
That's crazy.
That's a crazy line.
Oh, I see.
Yeah!
Okay.
What the fuck was that?
Alright, you pulled too hard!
Stop pulling it!
What was that?
I fucked up!
Oh my god.
Okay.
See, this is it!
This is why we're getting a divorce.
Okay.
Oh, we did it!
Yay!
It was just for an achievement.
Let's leave.
I wanna ride in the car.
Alright, alright.
Fine, fine, fine.
What the fuck?
You wanna ride in the car?
Is that what you want?
What?
Why did you do that?
What is going on?
Is that what you...
Whoa...
Is that what you want?
Yay!
I'm gonna ride in the car!
Where are we going?
Wait, can I send you through that hole?
Hold on.
Aim it, aim it.
Okay.
Well, there's an invisible wall there.
I'm gonna get out of here.
Alright.
I got this.
Go!
Go, wife!
What the fuck are you...
What?
What have you been waiting?
Go, wife!
Go!
Is that not how you talk to...
Talk to wife?
Hey, hey.
You know how I said to wait right there?
I can't read.
What do you mean you can't read?
I'm sorry.
What?
Okay, you have to do that again.
I thought it would be like an easy thing.
Alright.
What?
Did you just miss?
It's live!
How do you miss?
It's literally right in front of you!
I said it slid off.
Why?
How do you miss?
Wife!
Oh my god, look!
It's Woody!
How did you miss, wife?
What the fuck did I just see?
Nothing.
You didn't hit the flag!
You were supposed to hit the flag with Mario!
I was?
Now we can't get over.
I didn't grow up with Mario.
No, that's just an achievement.
Now we can't get over.
Here, the hole is the goal.
Now we can't get over to the secret side.
Oh yeah, blame the husband.
It's never your fault.
Wait, what's this?
There's like these green things.
What is that?
I don't know.
Wait, I think math is next!
I'm pretty sure this is the math area.
Wait, was this useless?
Was this...
Was this a useless thing to do?
Catching up!
I'm catching up!
I'm right here now!
Hey, what's going on?
I'm catching up!
What's going on?
Hey!
Oh shit!
Okay, you're back here with me!
Yeah!
Hey!
Oh fuck!
Okay!
Wait, I figured this out.
You can't do this without me, you know that!
It's fine, I'm here now.
What do we do?
Oh!
We have to press this at the same time!
Wait, but who's the...
Who's the...
Oh, because I have to go.
Oh!
Yeah, you go.
And then you...
And then you press...
Ah!
Mouse!
That's not a mouse, that's a dog!
Hey!
Look at the fucking...
Look at the teeth.
Okay, you have a...
Open the mouse!
Did you say open the mouse?
Horse!
Mouse!
Oh!
Baby!
Alright, Cody!
Come on over!
That wasn't so difficult, was it?
Okay, you can screen cheat by the way.
Oh my god!
You're pro... wait!
Wait, I said...
Why did you do that?
I am against screen peaking.
Oh yeah, now you're against screen peaking!
Yeah, now you are!
Alright!
What happened?
Dog!
Horse!
Lion!
Sheep!
Frog!
Ribbit!
Lion!
I hate that we have to work together.
Open it!
Is it great?
Yeah!
My beautiful wife!
Hello!
What took you so long?
My beautiful wife!
Who I love very much!
I fucking hate my husband.
Whoa!
I worked so hard to put food on the table!
And that's what you say?
Yeah, I'm the engineer, so...
Yeah!
And I'm a farmer!
Shut up!
Looks like we have to solve it?
Oh shit, it's this.
Wait, 6 plus 5?
6.
Oh, plus 3.
Yeah.
See?
Simple maths.
Yay!
Get off of 6, you bitch!
6 plus 1 makes 16.
You need to move an egg!
6 plus 1!
Well, this is embarrassing.
You suck at maths.
6 plus 1 makes what?
It makes 8.
2!
It's 2!
Okay, I'll go here now.
We can be 6 together.
You said this would be easy, man!
You're pissing me off!
Yay!
Get on 3 right now!
Okay...
Okay, where do I go?
Oh, I got 6!
Yeah!
Oh, what's this?
Okay, there's two cherries here.
Now they're not there anymore.
They're not there.
Orange.
Oh, strawberry.
I already forgot half of these.
Oh, strawberry!
Here!
And then... banana!
Cherry's a bo- Here, here, here!
No!
I actually- No!
Okay, that wasn't a cherry.
Where is eggplant?
Cherry!
Okay, we have two.
No, that's the eggplant.
Oh, thank god that was actually where the orange was.
More math!
That's not math.
It's numbers.
Oh, I can do that!
Wait, do you have- Can it just be you moving?
Push it!
Oh, I go up!
I go up!
And then you go- It's this way!
It's right!
And then seven is up.
What do you mean it's right?
I'm literally going right!
It's up!
It's down!
Okay.
Woah!
Why are you going to eleven?!
What do you mean?
I'm trying to- I'm trying to navigate, woman.
Trying to do what, woman?
Alright, sixty- Hey!
It's right side!
What are you doing?!
I'm literally going right!
No, you're not.
I feel the resistance!
Wait, where's the twenty?
Is it above me?
Oh!
Where the fuck did the twenty go?!
Where was the twenty?!
Right here!
Oh, I thought that was a twenty-six!
That looked like a twenty-six!
I couldn't tell!
Okay, you can move.
Okay.
I thought that was a- I thought that was a twenty-six!
I thought that was a twenty-six!
The zero was like- was like scratched off!
Okay.
Ten, eleven, twelve...
This is like- This does not look great.
This looks fucking ugly.
It's your fault.
Why is it my fault?!
It takes two to tangle!
Wow!
How did we fuck that up?!
You're taking too long!
How?!
I am really moving so fucking fast!
Alright, alright.
I am going so fast.
I'm pushing the- I'm pushing the crosshair.
Okay, here we go.
Nine...
Where are you going?!
Why do you keep forgetting ten?!
Why?!
What did ten do to you?!
How do we know it's me?
How do we know it's me?!
It takes two!
How- how- It literally says, it takes two.
How do you know it's my fault?
Because you keep going lower than we need to!
You don't know that.
As long as I get it in, that's all that matters.
What?
How?!
How did that happen?!
Like, I literally pressed it!
I literally pressed it!
I swear to God!
I swear that was not my fault.
I think that was not my fault.
Where are you going?!
Okay.
I am!
It's just, the drawing is supposed to be like this!
Okay.
What?
Fourteen... it was born this way.
Fifteen...
And then sixteen...
Seven...
Seen?!
Like, why does it do that?!
We went to seventeen!
That is not our fault!
I literally went to seventeen!
Went to seventeen!
I don't know what's wrong.
What?!
That wasn't even- That's not even my fault at that point!
Okay...
I don't know why we can't get past sixteen.
I don't know why.
Why?!
Why can't we do this?!
I can't understand!
I don't...
What's your sense on your mouth?!
I don't know.
No, it's not my fault!
It is not my fault!
Alright, I'm gonna let you move, okay?
There.
See, look.
I'm letting you do most of the heavy lifting now.
Where are you going?
To eleven.
Okay.
I can't move because of you!
I can't move either!
Okay.
Fourteen.
Alright.
Fifteen.
Sixteen.
See?!
That's not even us!
That's not- That's not even me!
That is not even me!
Google how to do!
That's not even me!
I swear to God!
It's not even me!
Help!
I'm all the way on the side now.
We stuck on this one of all fucking problems.
Change your mouse TPI.
What do you mean?!
My fucking TPI is high enough!
Okay, let's see.
Change into options!
Okay, which one?
Which one?
Am I Cody?
I'm Cody, right?
You're Cody.
Yeah, okay.
Horizontal- Wait, which one?
Do I change it to- Okay, I'm changing it to 30.
It's not me!
I swear to God!
Oh wait, back.
Okay.
Okay, I'm ready.
Okay, we should restart this now.
We should restart it because I was drawing a line.
Like, see?
Look at us.
Look at us go.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, it's very smooth.
Uh-huh.
How the fuck did we progress to 6 out of 16?
So fast.
I don't understand how we did that.
Maybe we go left.
I don't know.
Maybe we go left instead of up.
Okay.
And then- Oh my God!
We did it!
We have to go left!
Oh my God, we're making it.
We're doing it.
Go down.
Oh my God, we progressed.
We got past 16.
This is so easy now.
Go up.
I am!
24.
What the fuck is this stupid drawing?
It's a cat?
How the fuck did it make a cat?
That's one ugly ass cat.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
How the fuck did we make a cat?
Look at
the mouse.
Ooh!
That's us.
Oh, these games.
I had one of these when I was a kid.
Mousetrap?
No, like the...
Oh my God, it's way too high now.
The sensitivity.
Give me a sec.
I'm going back down.
This is way too high.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
I'm good.
How do we do this?
I don't think those nails matter.
Matter.
I'm ready.
Wait, what are you doing?
Wait, what?
You have to press the button to let the mouse out.
Wait, we do?
Like here?
How?
I don't think we let it out now.
I think we have to do these first.
Like the ones in front of us first.
We have to do this because there's an objective point here.
Am I green or blue?
You're green.
Oh, I'm green.
Alright.
How do we do this?
Oh, we have to stand on there.
We have to stand.
Yeah, and then we go up.
Oh my god, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
We're working together as a couple.
Our divorce is not a mess.
Our marriage is salvageable.
Barely.
What?
Hey, hey, there's still hope.
That means there's still hope.
Yay!
See?
We can fix our marriage.
Look at us go.
Yeah.
Even if it's not fixable, it wasn't my fault that this marriage died.
What?
I'm just saying, I think I was the better parent.
Yeah, okay.
No!
That could have been a child.
What?
Did I get it?
What if that ball right there is our child and this is a metaphor of how we take care of it?
I'm already out there.
Woo!
I know, it's all about control, man.
I did it!
Yay!
Where is the ball?
Where the fuck is the ball?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, now we push the thing.
Here we go, go get the cheese!
Here's the cheese, Mousy!
There it is!
Are you happy now?
Oh, that's torture.
That's actually torture.
What's this?
Oh!
What the heck?
Just move up.
And then, we have to make sure we jump fast enough.
But that's okay because we're gamers.
Ow.
.
Wait!
Wait up!
It's okay, we did it.
We're gamers.
.
Alright, hold on.
What do we do here?
Can we just jump on it?
Where do we go?
There's a rope thingy up there.
How do we get up there?
Wait, am I not supposed to wall jump?
I don't know.
Are we?
Oh!
Wait, what?
How do...
How?
I'm so confused.
Okay, I'm coming back.
Let's...
.
But like, how do we like...
Cause like, I can't do that though.
.
It's the side!
Yeah.
.
That's why I'm the gamer.
Yeah.
.
I figured it out.
I literally did that earlier.
.
I did it.
Okay.
.
I did it.
Oh my god.
I'm a genius husband.
.
Any women would be lucky to have me.
Eww.
.
What?
What is this?
.
Oh, it's the whoopee cushion.
Other one, other one, other one.
.
Alright.
Okay.
.
I pumped it.
Wait, then what?
.
What are you doing?
Oh, okay.
I pumped it.
.
I think you're supposed to land the other one.
Yeah.
.
I think you're supposed to...
Here and then...
.
There and then...
Oh, what?
.
Didn't you land on there?
Okay.
.
Wait, what?
Can you not get there?
.
Wait, do you have to launch that one?
I don't know.
.
What was that for?
What?
.
Oh!
Do we both have to?
.
Huh?
I think it's possible.
.
Wait, I think we...
It says pull my finger though.
.
Wait, what does that mean?
I'm letting you go up?
.
We both need to be on it.
And... what?
.
How did you... what?
How do I get there?
.
I can't get there.
Maybe you smash in and run over?
.
No, because there's a timer.
Oh, maybe?
Oh, maybe.
.
No?
Let's see.
.
Yeah, no, there's no...
There's like a delay.
.
Yeah, there's a delay.
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait!
.
Hold on.
Does pulling the finger make that spin?
.
No, why is it spinning?
Why is it pulled?
What's activated?
.
Oh, wait, there's a thing over there!
Do you see that?
.
There was a thing on top.
Is that the...
.
Oh, yeah!
There's a thing on top that's spinning!
.
There's a hook!
I see it!
.
There's a hook!
Wait, wait, wait!
Pull it, pull it!
.
Go here, go here.
There's a hook that shows up.
.
You'll see it.
There's a thing in there, and then there's a hook that shows up.
.
I see it now.
Wait, see the hook?
.
There's a hook right there!
No, I knew about the hook!
I tried to go for it earlier!
.
Yeah, but I think you're supposed to drop down after.
Wait, why do you keep... I did drop down!
.
Oh!
We figured it out together!
.
Yay!
We did it!
.
Together!
Because we are a lovely couple who's going through a rough patch.
.
Get on the...
Get on where?
.
Oh!
There you go.
I'm on it.
.
Yay!
I pulled the thing.
.
Okay, I'm gonna head over.
Can you jump again?
.
Alright, I'm on it.
We're a lovely couple.
.
I know.
Everybody thinks so.
.
We think we're made for each other.
God, I hope they never say that again.
.
We just have some little differences.
Look, that's why... we should go to like therapy instead.
.
Look, that's why...
we should go to like therapy instead.
.
You know, instead of... we should go to couples counseling.
Reddit, am I the asshole?
.
I hate my wife.
But it's her fault.
.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What's that?
.
Air dash?
What the fuck does that mean?
.
We just...
Where's the prize?
.
Give me something useful.
Just keep doing it?
.
Maybe we have to keep doing it.
What's this?
.
Air dash again.
That's it?
.
It has to be more, right?
Is that really it?
.
That's crotch.
It's crotch.
.
Oh my god, the watch.
Is that crotch?
.
Oh, crotch!
I thought this says crotch.
.
I was like, what the fuck is crotch?
Yay!
.
Wait, we can swim?
What does this do?
.
Oh, we can swim!
Yay!
.
Oh!
Don't swim.
.
I cranked this pipe all the way.
I don't know what I did though.
.
Don't swim.
Swimming was always a mistake.
.
Why did those balls fall?
No, the balls were always there.
.
Oh, we have to do this other one!
There's one over here.
.
I got it.
I'm pulling the lever.
.
Am I pulling it the right way?
It's spinning.
.
Oh, there it is!
Okay.
.
Teamwork!
Yay!
.
Alright, so we're going to couples counseling.
To fix our issues.
.
Oh my god, look!
Oh!
.
It's an Etch-a-Sketch!
I used to own one of these.
.
Me too.
What are we trying to draw?
.
I don't know, but I think we just made like...
A Marvel logo.
.
Now we just made Texas or something.
It's beautiful.
.
What the fuck are you making?
It looks like Stonehenge.
.
I stopped touching the thing.
Wait, was that it?
.
It wasn't like an actual game?
Wait, we can make...
.
Shut up!
What was I going to say?
.
I don't know.
I just wanted to...
.
What was I going to say?
Clearly you think I'm going to say something.
.
What was I going to say?
I'm going to put the last coin in.
.
I'm doing the teeth.
Oh my god, yay!
.
So cute!
Come over here.
.
I'm going to smash this.
I did five and I was okay.
.
It's your turn.
Okay.
Your turn.
.
Nice.
What is this?
.
It's like a little...
Our kid is like ten or some shit.
.
She should not be reading this.
Dude, I think these were her old toys.
.
Oh my god, game, game, game!
Game?
Oh!
What's this?
.
It's a bat time?
Swing a bat.
.
Oh, this will be a piece of cake.
Let me do this.
.
Alrighty!
Oh.
.
Let it go!
Oh!
.
It took my ball forever to get that.
You just didn't hit it hard enough.
.
Oh god.
I'm missing now.
.
Boom!
You're out of here!
.
Please!
Look at that.
I'm going so fast.
.
There you go!
It's because if you... No!
Fuck!
No, no, no, no!
.
It's because if you miss...
It's because if you miss... .
It's true.
.
You have to like, have a...
It's true.
.
Have a rhythm.
Oh!
Next!
.
The more you go, the faster you are.
I keep sending it backwards.
.
You hit it at the right angle.
It's alright.
.
That's why I'm mansplaining.
Oh thank you, husband!
.
Oh husband, we can't afford rent.
You keep buying too many battle pass.
.
I did it, wife!
Are you proud of me?
Please!
Husband, please stop buying battle pass.
We can't afford dinner.
But I gotta get my John Cena!
You wouldn't understand.
You wouldn't understand, Rumi.
Husband, please.
But what about- who the fuck we bought fidget spinners?
Your baby ain't hurt too much.
In the real world, yes!
Yeah, that's right.
Gumi's not a gamer if she's trying to restrict my Fortnite passes.
Husband, we need to eat.
We could eat or...
Or we could have the John Cena skin.
Wait, what?
I landed.
Where do I have to go?
Oh, over there.
Where else would we go?
I don't know!
What?
Okay.
That was weird.
Alright, I got it.
I'm twisting the knob.
That's my special move.
Ew.
What?
Why?
Why did you use that?
What did twisting this do?
I don't know, actually.
What did it do?
What does that open up?
Oh, it's over to the...
Can we have to go back there?
Isn't it here?
There's a... it's over here.
Oh yeah, do that one.
Yeah, there's one here.
Alright, twisting the knob.
Your favorite move.
I'm gonna need you to stop coughing once and for all.
I don't understand!
What did I say?
What the fuck did I say?
Twisting these knobs should turn this pipe off.
Well, we have to find the yellow pipe.
I found it.
It's over behind us.
What do you mean?
We already did the yellow pipe.
No, we didn't.
We did the purple pipe.
There's the yellow pipe right here.
There, I got you.
What was the purple pipe for then?
I don't know.
I mean, free up the red.
What?
It's free up the red.
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
Then we head over there.
Oh my god!
Doki carry!
I know!
I'm carrying!
I need a break from last week.
What?
Let's go to the beach!
Beach!
Yay!
Ja ja!
We bought our daughter a bouncy castle?
You didn't go?
We bought her a bouncy... Is this why we're having money issues?
Hey, I make the money.
You're the one that's in charge of home.
And you've been spending it.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
There's no way I bought this for her.
I'm too busy fucking farming.
How the fuck...
It can't be... I think it has to be you.
You're trying to compensate for your lack of...
Lack of what?
Lack of presence in our daughter's life.
You're trying way too hard to compensate for this.
Yeah, okay, bud.
You're like the one where you're at work like 20 hours out of the 24 hours.
And then you come home with a bouncy castle.
Wait, I had a bouncy castle when I was a kid.
Yeah.
Okay, don't think too hard about that.
Don't think too hard about that.
You mean it?
I'm just talking about this game.
It's not related to anything in real life.
It's just... It's just about... It's just this game.
I'm just talking about a hypothetical in this game.
You mean it really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, I have to smash it.
Yay!
I hate this guy.
Me too.
Oh, no!
Oh, here we go again.
My plan is working!
You like each other more now!
This guy fucking sucks.
But there are more things to learn and new challenges to overcome!
Let's keep on going!
We got a relationship to fix!
Woohoo!
What the hell?
Oh, God, that's trippy.
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this.
I don't like that.
Oh!
I love kaleidoscopes.
Oh, this is... Oh!
I don't like this!
Oh, my God!
This is way too fucking trippy.
This is actually way too uncomfortable.
Why does everything have to be a rollercoaster?
That would suck, actually.
Haha!
Dude, how the fuck... How long does this go for?
Okay.
Here we go.
Is it like... Oh, does it... Maybe if I... Okay, no, don't jump off.
Don't jump off!
Oh!
No, not that.
What?
We have to...
What do I have to do?
Me...
Oh, wait, stand... Stand over there.
Where?
Here?
Try and connect it.
Yeah.
No, one more.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
This is why you're the engineer.
Stand here, where I'm standing.
Okay.
Oh, my God!
We're so smart together, sweetie!
Nice stubby, hurt, hearty choke.
Yeah, it's like a freaking double rainbow in here!
Oh, my God!
Double rainbow!
What the fuck is that?
What is that?
That's us!
Oh, my God!
Double!
Is that good?
Now that there's two of us?
No.
Wait!
Eiffel Tower.
Where are we supposed to make... Go up.
Go up top right.
I did it.
We did it!
Yeah.
And then...
Whoa!
Does that mean there's gonna be four of us?
I don't know.
My stubby hurt.
Why?
Is it because of the artichokes?
Too much fiber.
I told you not to eat all those artichokes.
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh, my God.
I really don't like this.
Oh... Oh...
Oh, finally!
How do we do this?
Oh.
Here we go.
And then I guess I...
Go from here?
Oh, okay.
I'm up.
And then...
Oh.
I see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
And then what?
Do I just bring you over?
Oh, I bring you to the blue?
Yeah.
I think you can let go of it now.
Yeah, but like... Oh!
No, I can't.
Yeah, you can.
Oh, I... Oh, wait.
You can.
Okay.
I'm on it.
And then we're here together!
What do we do here?
We push it together?
Oh.
Whoa!
Oh, we're refracting it.
We're going up.
What is happening?
Kaleidoscope time.
This is what's in your kaleidoscope.
You little people.
You're a doll, Cody.
You're nothing to throw up.
Oh!
Ew!
What the fuck was that?
It's clay.
I'm made of clay?
I thought it was made of wood.
You're sniffing it?
I'm like a dog.
You know it's healthy for a dog to...
Oh, that's easy.
We just have to get to the Magic Castle.
Oh, God.
Which I built, by the way.
You built the Magic Castle?
Yeah.
Yeah, you're not the only one in the family who can build cool stuff.
I built the Magic Castle?
God, I'm so smart.
Right over there.
That'll take us straight there.
You're sure?
Yes, I am sure.
Would you just trust me?
I'll try.
Thank you.
Can I go pee first?
Okay.
No.
Come on.
Let's clear the way for the hangar.
What the hell?
Don't say anything weird while I'm gone.
Wait, what constitutes as weird?
What's considered weird?
Guys, what would be weird anyway?
Oh my gosh, I got a little person right here.
Whoop.
This little person.
What do I do with this?
I shoot the plane?
The fuck am I...
I'm so confused.
Oh, that's a telescope.
I'm so confused without my wife.
She knew what to do.
All I did was take credit.
The doki way.
I was so good at one thing.
And it was to just take credit.
What do I do?
Oh, hey, nice.
I brought it over.
Wait!
That's so...
Oh my god, I could just die with this thing and I'll bring it over.
I assume that's what it's for.
Say something weird?
My existence.
No!
Did I cheese that puzzle?
It's not cheesing, it's strats.
Watch this.
I pick it...
I pick this guy up.
I pick this guy up and I go down.
Easy.
I got everything.
Right?
That's all of them.
It's okay.
She's not here.
She'll never know what I said.
So I can continue to take credit for things I didn't do.
That's the best part.
Oh my god, guys!
Today...
I finalized my skin suit design.
Today I...
Not today.
Last night!
At like 5 in the morning!
I finalized it.
I don't know if you guys are gonna like it but I don't have to worry about it anymore.
Thank fucking god!
I was like freaking out about shit for the longest time.
So I'm just happy I don't have to think about it anymore.
Oh yeah, Gumi tried to get me to play TFT.
Because apparently she's like in this...
Wait...
Oh, did I cheese this?
Cause like I already got the thing.
Yeah, I cheesed it.
Oh my god, that's how I did it?
Oh yeah, and she was trying to get me to play TFT cause she has this TFT tournament or some shit.
And I was like, Gumi, I can't even...
I only played one game of TFT.
And like there's no way I'm gonna play TFT cause the whole thing about TFT is reading.
It is.
I was like, there's no way you're gonna get me to play TFT.
I'm not gonna fucking read.
It's... oh, it's like team...
I almost said team fortress tactics.
Team fight tactics?
Right?
Is that what it means?
I don't have the brain capacity for that.
All I do is just... I exist.
My one weakness, reading.
I don't have the brain power.
What the fuck is she kissing?
Is she kissing the mailman?
Who is she trying to kiss?
The mailman?
Woah, woah, woah!
Choo!
Oh my god.
She's gonna kiss the mailman.
How could she?
In front of him?
Right in front of him?
Just like that?
Oh, there you are.
I did it!
Gume!
I fixed... I solved the puzzle!
Really?
Yeah!
Now give me a kiss for a good job.
Well done.
Mwah!
Wow, that was so hot.
Oh my god, you're gonna get me excited.
Ew!
Why am I pee-pee hard?
I want to go get some Tums because I hid them from myself.
Why did you hide it?
Because I have a Tums addiction.
I think they're really yummy.
What is it, Tums?
It...
Why?
I don't know what Tums is.
It's a... It's an anti-acid.
Oh!
Wait.
Wouldn't that like fuck your stomach up?
Because you're eating it out of pure enjoyment and not for...
Yeah, no, you're only supposed to have seven maximum per day.
Wait, what?
And how much... how many do you have?
Well, I usually eat seven per day.
Oh, that is... whoa!
That is not good.
Oh, look, the dinosaurs!
I've never had Tums before.
So, I had to hide them for myself.
Because out of sight, out of mind.
Oh!
Aww!
What happened to you straight to the castle route?
I didn't put the dinosaur there.
Whatever.
Let's just find a way to clear the track.
What?
How?
I don't think I've ever had Tums.
I just like... If I Tummy her, I just suffer.
That one can help us.
It only makes you stronger.
Well, any Tums also?
Yeah, when I drink...
Because it helps with the acid from drinking.
Oh!
Yeah, I don't drink a lot.
That's why.
What do we do here?
What?
I remember the last time we drank together.
Yeah, that was a long time ago.
I don't know if you remember, but that was a long...
Yeah, you abandoned me.
Yeah, that was a long time ago.
Wait, what's this?
You take the red one on the platform.
Oh, there's a red one!
Where?
They were there.
I just let him go.
Oh.
There you go.
There's the Stegosaurus.
Did you know that Brontosaurus is not a real dinosaur?
What is it then?
Like, apparently back then, when they made the Stegosaurus, they like, they like just pieced together random dinosaur bones.
And then they're like, this is a Brontosaurus.
Hey.
Oh, that's not a Stegosaurus!
That's a... that's a... that's a... I don't know what the fuck that is.
What?
I don't know what it's called.
Wait, I can't push that.
You have to do it yourself.
No, no, no.
You have to pull it first.
Oh!
There you go.
Where are our Jurassic Park enthusiasts here?
But yeah, apparently like...
Wait, I did... oh, I pulled it.
But yeah, but like back then, when they did dinosaur stuff, they were like...
They didn't know like...
I can't grab it?
Oh, because I didn't go down.
There you go.
I'm back!
Wait, what are you doing?
No, you need to grab the other one.
Oh, okay.
No, I don't.
But I do.
There you go.
Get on.
My lady.
Yeah?
What do you do now?
Bring me back.
That's why I wanted to talk to you.
There you go.
Okay.
They said you were wrong.
Grab that one.
I grabbed it.
Okay.
Wait, I know you're supposed to wait for me to grab it.
But back in the day, when they were constructing dinosaurs, like what we know about the dinosaurs.
Back then was like mostly wrong because the scientists didn't know what the fuck they were doing.
And they were just piecing random bones together until it made something.
Can you grab that one?
No, if I grab this one, the other one will disappear.
Because you grab this and then you knock the other one.
I think that changes it.
Trust me.
No.
Do my idea first.
How about that?
It's entertainment.
You can entertain my idea first.
And then like if I was right...
If I was wrong, you can say I told you so.
Okay.
There you go.
Wow.
You were right.
It's like I knew what I was talking about.
And then...
And then I'm going to grab onto this and you knock it.
Wow.
What was that?
Who is that?
Sorry I just really don't trust you.
Okay, let me see.
There's something...
Grabbing.
No.
We have to...
I have to grab onto the other one.
Well, don't you want to grab onto them first?
Well, I can't grab onto that.
Because like, it's... you have to...
What do you want to grab?
Just hold on.
Okay.
Okay, well...
Okay, I'm grabbing on.
Grabbing onto this.
Okay, let go.
Let go.
Alright.
Hold the other one.
Alright, I'm grabbing onto it.
Okay.
Okay, I already did it.
Let me on!
Don't worry.
I'm here.
Look how cute this one is.
The hero is here.
Yeah, but do you have my size?
Size isn't what matters, man.
You taught me that.
I said that.
Wait, wait a minute.
What do you mean I taught you that?
I said that.
Look at him.
Oh, that's not my fault.
They totally saw that coming.
Okay, don't worry.
I got you.
See, look at that.
My guy is still alive.
If your guy wasn't so small, he'd be alive.
What the f... How did you miss?
I'm not even that far.
I thought you would wait for me to land on it.
I thought I'd be able to bring you to the side.
I don't know.
You should know by...
You're married to me.
You should know by now how I play this game.
Oh, now you don't trust me.
There, I got you.
What am I pulling up?
What am I pulling up though?
What is this?
I'm making a second wall jump.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I got it.
I figured it out.
Yay!
Thank you.
Your hero is here.
Do not worry.
I'm gonna go.
I was afraid to call you a hero.
Your hero is here.
Oh my god, we gave him a concussion!
We're monsters!
That was fucked up.
Ew!
Where the fuck did the gas come from?
Up we go!
Yay!
Do we have to have a sensitive nose?
Do these players have...
Do these characters...
Do this mom and dad have friends outside of just the relationship?
Like, do we have friends?
I feel like...
Oh my god.
I feel like it's just us two.
This is not healthy.
We need friends outside of the relationship.
We isolated each other.
We're like...
You can't... I don't...
I don't like Michael.
You can't be friends with him anymore.
If you have any guys on your friends list, you're gonna cheat on me.
Can you delete all of them?
I had a guy who actually did that.
He made me...
Do you want me to... Do you want to look at my phone too?
Here!
I have all my passwords!
This is all my passwords!
Look!
There's my password!
There's my contacts!
Are we...
Are we bad for each other?
I'm gonna go this way.
I'm gonna do it.
Ow.
Yeah, don't sink it!
Yeah!
No!
It's a group ember!
Shoot the fucking octopus!
What do you mean?
I'm not the one for shooting!
We both can shoot!
Wait, we can?
How do I shoot?
Oh!
Oh my god!
I'm doing it!
I didn't realize that's how you shoot!
We have to shoot this thing!
Fireworks!
Someone was like...
Don't divorce!
Don't!
Mom!
Dad!
Don't do it!
It's too late.
It's your fault.
Alright, I'm gonna kill this guy.
I'm doing my part.
Alright, here we go.
We're doing it!
Die, octopus!
You don't even need to kill them to be fair, I feel like.
I think so.
Our ship has health.
I think sometimes we can just ride past them.
Is this the water level where you're gonna shoot a big octopus?
Maybe.
I hate those levels.
Oh, I fucking knew it.
We don't have to do this!
We come in peace!
I don't like their cannons.
Who the fuck put water?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think we missed.
We're a little too early.
Oh, this is bad!
This is bad!
What do you mean, Doki?
Doki?
What do you mean?
This is...
What happened to...
This is a group effort.
What happened to that?
I literally have never said that line.
You're the one that kept saying that!
You're the one that kept saying it!
Now it's my fault just because we took a little damage!
It's now my fault!
I see you!
I remember all the times you ran into the fucking...
That is a pass!
I'm a better person now!
Really?
Yeah, I've changed.
You don't have to leave.
I've changed.
You fixed me.
I promise I'll treat you better!
Oh, penguins!
Where do we shoot that one penguin over there?
Straight into the icebox now!
Oh, we can't shoot them.
Don't worry.
I wanted a voice.
What?
I didn't sign the prenup!
You know what?
That's more beneficial.
Oh!
Oh my god, you see it?
What?
Oh, the giant octopus.
I see it.
Wait, how do we...
How do we dodge that?
Oh my god!
How do we do?
Do we shoot it?
Yeah!
Oh!
You didn't tell me!
What happened to context clues?
I felt like it was obvious.
No, it was not.
No, it wasn't.
You know I need to be told what to do.
You know I...
You know damn well I'm a little special.
And that's why you fell in love with me.
This was arranged by your parents.
They lost the bet.
Hey, Mr. Octopus!
Don't listen to her.
You are super cute!
Hey, you're so...
Nick Ryder!
Ship!
Oh!
Whoa!
Also, you're an engineer.
You're so good at engineering.
Fix our ship.
Stop talking, Cody!
And start shooting!
It's the point of having that degree if you can't even fix our boat.
It's a whirlpool!
Oh!
We're gonna shoot the...
There we go!
Okay, there we go.
We're good.
We're okay.
Nothing to worry about.
Keep firing!
We're not panicking.
Nothing to panic about.
Oh god.
Alright.
Nice.
We gotta turn around now.
I mean, it's pretty easy so far.
Cause he has a giant head.
Why do you say things?
What do you mean?
We got full HP now!
Keep them away!
See?
Oh god.
It's a duck with dynamite.
Who the fuck gave a kid a dynamite?
I heard it!
Who the fuck gave this kid a dynamite?
How does she know how to make a bomb?
Why is it?
No, I got her the castle.
You're the engineer.
This is engineer stuff.
Why would a farmer know how to make a bomb?
Why do you think I fucking engineered bombs?
Oh god.
Oh, wait.
How the fuck do we...
Oh, it's okay.
It was just special effects.
Oh yeah!
You alright, mate?
It was just a cutscene.
Wait, there's more.
There's a tentacle!
There's a door!
Okay.
I don't think we can ignore that one guy.
Cause he's just...
He's just existing.
Oh no.
Not the flip.
What the flip?
Hey, have you seen that video that was like a monkey flipping and goes... What?
And it had like American music to it?
What?
What do you mean by that?
I like how this... You don't know monkey flip?
No!
I think you live on the internet a lot more than me.
Oh, we're gonna get hit.
I think we can just tank this and... Oh.
I'm pretty sure we can just tank this and shoot the octopus.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay, let me get you monkey flip real quick.
What the fuck is monkey flip?
Monkey...
Hold on.
Monkey flip.
I said in the real world it was cute.
And did not try to kill me.
Oh wait.
I did buy her this.
I'm a good dad.
I care about my child.
Because...
He likes it.
Here, I sent it to you.
Monkey flip.
Okay, what the fuck?
It goes...
Woah!
This is what she sent.
Okay.
Okay, well you...
I didn't realize that you were actually singing this song to monkey flip.
I just realized my fucking chrome tablet's off.
No!
I swear!
I swear if I get DMCA'd...
I swear...
I get DMCA'd because of... I fucking...
I'm fucking swag!
That's not my fault.
What do you mean you sent me the link?
You had the chrome tablet.
I didn't realize I had my chrome on.
It was so high.
Sound guy, fix it.
I replayed it.
It was guaranteed.
This is kinda like that haunted house.
Monkey.
Monkey flip.
Every time we flipped into Octopus, that's when my brain went...
Woah!
I just hope we survive this ride too!
How are we still not finished with this chapter?
What the fuck is this level?
The bridge isn't supposed to be up!
Gosh, it's winched by a balloon!
Hey, that's Rosie's balloon!
Who the fuck uses the word winched?
Oh yeah, I hate that creepy balloon.
Why'd you have to buy her that?
Yeah.
Why?
See, not everything's my fault.
Oh god.
Oh, what the fuck?
What parent would buy this for their child?
What millennial parent would buy this for their child?
Dude, don't we look like millennials here?
I'm saying, why would millennials buy this?
Millennials won't buy this.
They'll just buy an iPad.
I'm pretty sure this was before iPads existed, man.
There's no way.
Rose gave the elephant a crown.
You know, a queen's crown.
Dude, we live in a fucking farm.
Yeah, I guess so.
It's her favorite toy.
Oh, perfect.
So now we're killing a queen.
Pardon me, killing who?
No, no, no, no, no.
She said chilling!
This was made before Queen Elizabeth.
Yeah, chilling with the queen we are really looking forward to.
Okay, that does not mean much.
Chilling with her, right?
I see.
Well, our visitors must prove themselves worthy of an office visit.
So, let's get the audience with the queen.
Get a ball over there.
And use it to pop the balloon.
And then you will...
This is messed up.
Why is she helping us kill the queen?
Thank you!
Is the queen that bad?
She doesn't know we're killing the queen, man.
Okay, but it could be implied.
We literally... the storyline talked about that.
They said we're chilling with the queen.
Yeah, but like...
Did she really believe that?
Oh, I don't have to be there.
Wait.
Oh, and then we do this.
And then it goes over to the other side.
Oh, we did it!
This is...
We have to run.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Wait, did you not do the thing?
I'm holding the ball.
I'm holding it.
You have to turn the wheel to the right.
Okay, I got it.
I figured it out.
Together with my lovely wife.
Look at the sea!
Oh, look at the sea!
Okay, I...
I just want to enjoy this beautiful view a little longer.
Have you ever watched the Cirque du Soleil?
What play?
The circus.
Oh, yeah.
I went and saw Cirque du Soleil.
Okay, I saw Cirque du Soleil two times in my life.
And the fucked up thing...
Okay, you know how Cirque du Soleil...
Okay, I have to look this up.
But Cirque du Soleil has lots and lots and lots of shows.
Did I fuck up?
Wait, you missed.
Okay.
Okay, let me try that again.
Did you get the other balloon?
Yeah, you have to aim at the one between the bars.
Or you can aim at that one.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Maybe you should.
Maybe you're better at this than me.
Oh, are you sure?
I literally did not say a word and you're just talking to yourself.
You're literally just talking to yourself.
I don't know what to tell you.
You're like, oh, maybe you're better than me.
Are you sure?
I didn't say a single line.
Are you sure this is how you're supposed to do it?
I don't think you can go through that.
Oh, maybe we have to curve it through the side.
I don't think you can.
I think we're supposed to do that the one to that one first and then that's gonna open the gate.
Why would you shoot me now?
Because I'm timing it.
There, see?
Look at that.
I timed that fucking perfectly!
You know timings?
Oh my god!
I actually timed that perfectly!
What are you doing?
I didn't know you knew timings, man.
That's gonna close the moment you get there.
Wait, what?
What?
No, we have to get the center.
There's the center right there.
I...
Why did you not see me hit that button?
No, I did!
I did!
But I'm saying, there's also this one that we have to get.
Okay, anyway, so...
I saw Cirque du Soleil has like...
60 plus shows.
60 plus fucking shows.
And like, I remember going to the first Cirque du Soleil when I was like really, really, really little.
And...
I really enjoyed Cirque d'Art.
Because it was like my first Cirque du Soleil.
So I was like, alright.
Uh...
I wanna buy the CD of it.
So then I had it in my...
I had it in my iTunes for like years and like 10 plus years.
Maybe longer.
Maybe like 15 plus years.
And I would listen... It would come up in my playlist ever so often.
Because I still have my, you know, I listen to it on my iPhone.
Like, I always sync it up on my iPhone.
And then... And then, I was...
Luckily enough, I was able to watch a new Cirque du Soleil.
Um...
A new Cirque du Soleil.
And...
I didn't realize like what show it was.
I was just like, oh Cirque du Soleil.
Clearly it will be like a new show.
I listened... The first act.
It was the same show I watched 15 plus years ago.
Like I somehow was able to go back and watch that same show.
15 years ago!
When there is...
That's not new.
That's not...
I didn't even move my entire thing.
I did not move nothing.
There is 16 plus Cirque du Soleil shows.
And I somehow was able to watch the same one.
Like how?
How is that possible?
I'm sorry.
I had to talk about it.
It actually pissed me off when I found out.
No, I don't know.
Honestly, I can't even remember Cirque du Soleil.
I feel like my mom like fell asleep during it.
I only remembered because I was like the first act.
I was like, wait a minute.
I know this song.
I was like, why would I know this song if I haven't fucking watched it?
If I haven't had that song those songs in repeat for so long.
Where do we go?
Oh, I have to pass it to you.
Are you ready?
Catch!
Oh my god.
We're so good.
It's like we're gamers.
That's nice, honey.
Is that an American thing?
I have no idea.
No, it's a circus thing.
Cirque du Soleil is like one of the biggest circuses in the world.
And I somehow was able to watch the same show twice with a 15 plus year gap in between.
Like, I don't know how it was possible.
But like I somehow was able to do it.
Honestly, I did not... Oh, what the fuck?
We did it.
We weren't even coordinating that.
Oh my god, it looked at us!
It looked at us before it died.
We will.
Thanks for your help.
Yeah, thanks a lot.
Let's get to the castle.
Yay, we committed mur... I feel like he would know we're committing murder now after we killed that balloon.
Still can't believe I watched the same show.
Honestly, why did that person let us do that?
Maybe she really hated that clown.
Maybe that clown was a fucking asshole.
I mean, look at him.
He looks like an asshole.
Why do we have to kill the queen?
Too many taxes.
Okay.
Viva la France.
What?
You don't know French history?
Hold on, you said you never finished building the chat.
No, it's more like...
I just did not expect you to see that.
It's time for the revolution.
It's time!
Get the guillotine!
Oh my god, they must have guillotines!
This is medieval times now.
Oh my god, no!
Honestly, hold on.
If I had to die... Yeah?
If you if.
If I got to choose how I would die...
Yeah?
I would want to go buy a guillotine.
What the fuck?
Why?
Do you know like you can like...
Like the head starts... You know you still process like 10 seconds?
Hey.
Why?
Why a guillotine?
Okay, hear me out.
Hold on, hear me out.
Okay.
It would be so cool.
Like I'm not gonna die from old age.
I would go buy guillotine and I would DYI it.
I would make my own.
You know like if you make your own, it doesn't guarantee that you're gonna get the slice right.
And?
Hold on.
And I would trademark that shit and name it the guillotine.
The guillotine?
What the fuck would you... It already exists.
Like you can't trademark something that already exists.
What is... No.
What is the guillotine gonna look... How is the guillotine gonna look different?
Hold on, hold on.
Hold on.
I'll show you.
The guillotine has something different to it.
Are you ready?
Yeah, okay.
I'm gonna draw for you real quick.
You're gonna draw for me real quick.
So, the average guillotine... Here, I'll even square it.
Okay.
Well, let me see...
See what this is.
Alright.
So, the guillotine, it's usually like this, and then it's like this, and then it's like this, and then it has like this blade here.
And then you put your little head here.
Right?
And then they usually have a bucket to catch the head.
A bucket?
What?
Oh, you mean like a bucket to catch the...
to catch the head.
The head.
Yeah.
But that's what the normal guillotine has.
Yeah, that's the normal guillotine.
But this is the guillotine.
First of all, it would have little ears.
Okay?
Let's get that straight.
And then...
Instead of a normal blade, the little blade would have little teeth.
And it would look like this.
And then...
It would be right here.
And that would be me.
That would be...
Try yourself!
What the fuck?
That would be me.
And then, hold on.
I can't see it yet!
What do you mean?
The string would be a little dog treat.
The what would be a little dog treat?
You know the like pulley thing?
How you pull it to make those...
Oh!
Oh, so the dog...
You won't know exactly when.
It's whenever the dog decides to pull... That's so fucked up.
That is actually so fucked up.
So the only thing different about it is that it's controlled by a dog.
So you're trying to say it'll make people feel less bad because a dog did it?
Is that why?
No!
I'm not gonna make a dog do it.
It's just bone shaped.
It's just like branding.
You're not trademarking the guillotine because you're just branding it.
It has freaking teeth and everything!
It's just like you put on a Fortnite skin on it.
It's still Fortnite.
You put on a gooby skin on it.
It's still a guillotine.
It's still... Who trademarked a guillotine?
Who trademarked a guillotine?
It would be fucked up if somebody trademarked a guillotine.
So every time you use a guillotine you have to pay.
You have to pay the trademark rights to it.
That's why we don't even have... Wait, the guillotine is trademarked as a game.
Wizards of the Coast!
Wait!
Dungeons and Dragons trademarked the guillotine!
What the fuck?
Okay, but they can't trademark the goomy teen.
Oh my god!
Magic the Gathering and Dungeons and Dragons trademarked the guillotine!
That's so fucked up!
Why did they...
Hold on.
What if I add a thing?
Instead of a bucket?
Yeah, you...
It's already trademarked.
You can't do it.
No, they can't trademark the goomy teen!
It's different!
It's a skin!
You see people trade my shit like Fushigi!
Fushigi is just a weird weighted ball!
Or like...
Whoa!
Damn, you're so passionate about the Magic Gravity Ball!
What the fuck?
Why did you bring up that?
The most obscure shit ever!
Why did you bring it up?
Goomy, start the game!
Start the fucking game!
And pause the game!
I think you've cooked long enough!
You never even showed me the goomy teen!
You drew all that out and I never got a chance to see it!
That's the goomy teen!
You never even showed me the goomy teen!
On the right hand side!
What do you mean the right hand side?
You sure did!
I showed you my drawing!
No you did not!
I did not see it!
You did not show...
I guess it didn't screen share properly.
You were screen sharing?
Yeah, I was!
I was gonna screen share!
Sorry I wasn't listening.
I thought you were gonna screen share it.
I didn't realize you still have the picture.
Can you screen share it for me?
No I already closed paint!
Get down!
You'll never see the goomy teen!
It looks so different!
I was like why does she not see this?
Okay there's a game here.
It's a true game.
It's a train track too!
Wait what the fuck?
Is this squeeze the bird to make it sing?
Oh!
I think it's a...
What is this?
Oh bird star!
World star!
Oh!
It's like a rhythm game.
Whatever rhythm.
Kinda cute.
Bump!
When does it get harder?
Easy!
I don't know.
Well done birdie!
This is so easy.
Bring it home!
I need to eat another tub.
Bump!
Oh fuck!
I didn't realize you can't spam it!
Oh no!
Oh god it's getting too hard!
It's getting too hard!
Yes!
Here is team bluebird!
I'm not that good at rhythm.
It's okay.
I'm good at other things.
That's why you marry me.
Yeah.
Oh I don't have a birthday party!
It's like somebody's birthday.
Hurry help!
Give me a sec.
I'm ruining somebody's...
I'm ruining somebody's birthday.
That's fucking right.
Management did not give you a birthday.
Oh!
I love a birthday!
What story is that?
Oh you're helping.
He's been a sticky white subject.
What the fuck?
Oh wait!
Look!
He's in the other one!
Yeah I think it's over for him.
No it's okay!
I got you!
Why are you always in the sticky substance?
What is that anyway?
Oh yeah it's over.
He is a pattern.
I can't believe you ruined their birthday.
I didn't ruin it.
Management said they're not allowed to have a birthday.
Alright!
Let's see if we can get a better view of the castle.
Where are you going?
I'm on the team.
Choo choo!
This is like...
Oh!
Oh my god!
This is a huge area.
Oh there's a printer!
There's paint!
What the hell?
Oh my god!
I'm making art!
I'm making beautiful art!
Oh!
It's so beautiful!
Beautiful is not the word I would use for that.
You're not even looking!
You're on your fucking train!
It's like you love the train more than me.
Choo choo!
Maybe I do!
That's fucked up.
How would you ever say that?
What can the train do that I can't?
Oh lord!
I'm working right now.
What can the train do that I can't?
I don't understand.
What are we supposed to do here?
The gate's locked!
But there's got to be a way in!
Is there?
I think I found what we're supposed to do.
But like, what if I just want to live here?
It seems like a good place to live.
Uhhh...
CPS?
Evidence number...
27.
Why are you calling it on us?
I'm calling it on you!
You can't because it's a group effort.
If I fuck up as a parent, it's on you too.
Why do you keep saying that?
So we got this big crane here.
I'm sure it could be useful for this gate.
God, go down.
Oh, interior.
It's a group effort.
We can't fuck it up individually.
We have to fuck it up as a team.
Why are you moving it that way?
Oh, it's Jenga!
Satisfying!
Wait, what's the point of that?
There was no point.
We had to do this anyway.
No, I couldn't go the other way.
Oh!
You're crazy!
How do we push it?
Did you hear him?
No, I don't...
He said you're crazy, but I like it.
Woah!
I can fix her.
Oh, I have to jump in.
Jump in!
We have to move it together.
Oh, so you're the crazy one and I'm trying to fix you.
Okay, okay.
I knew I was the normal one.
Any man that said my ex...
I knew I was the...
Dude, I dated a guy who said all my exes were crazy.
He was the problem.
That's full of cum.
Are you trying to say I'm the problem?
Wait, wait, wait.
We're not here to cause trouble.
I am.
That guy, me.
Wait.
That sounds a lot like Winx.
Queen of the Magic Castle.
In short, her majesty.
Oh, yes, you mean her majesty.
Can you take us to her?
It's kind of urgent.
The queen does not grant audience with peasants.
Peasants?
We made them!
Okay, I built this castle.
I even came up with the name Magic Castle.
So if it wasn't for me, you would be the one.
Oh, what a little bit.
Excuse my underling, ma'am.
Underling?
We are messengers from a land far, far away.
We come with a very important letter for her majesty.
Hand it over.
Oh, well, um, we need to see her majesty in person.
It's a letter in words.
Hmm, why?
Whoa!
Because they want to kill the queen.
What?
This book is a fucking asshole.
Yeah, snitch.
You snitch.
Yeah, dick rider.
It's a speech letter.
I can't write.
There is no letter!
Case closed!
Oh!
Hold on, I received a screenshot.
Is this like off-brand Lego?
Are we too poor to buy real Lego?
Thank you, Ravdude.
I've sent you the screenshot that my moderator sent me.
Not being this great in years.
Oh my god, they gave us a toilet!
Wait, no!
There's different toys that look just like that.
Yeah, I don't remember what.
It wasn't Legos, they were bigger.
No, it's Playmobil.
Yeah!
Is Playmobil like Lego?
Anyone hear us?
I sent you the screenshot.
I know Lego has like baby Lego.
You're lucky for us.
Duplo.
Oh, Duplo!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you mind?
What are you doing?
I built that.
Yeah, I can see that.
The toilet has no pipes.
Yeah?
It's a toy castle.
Toys don't go to the bathroom.
Yeah.
Toys don't need to eat.
Why did it have a pie?
That's right.
It was a waste of food.
Those toys don't need to eat anyway.
I really shouldn't have skipped those beans.
Ew.
It's like paper.
How am I weaker than paper?
Oh no!
Am I getting...
too flabby?
Ew.
Did you shard yourself or something?
Why are you pulling your pants like that?
What the fuck?
Over here, quick!
Come on!
I think you sharded.
Stop!
Shard?
Why?
This is a kids game.
This is a children's game.
This is PGA.
We are a PG friendly stream.
Hahaha.
Didn't know what shard means.
Oh my god!
We killed him!
You killed him!
I get a cool fire sword.
How the fuck do you get the cool weapons?
Oh wait, but then you get melee.
I get FPS.
You know what?
I'm fine with that.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
It's like...
I know this type of game.
Okay, wait.
I'm trying to look at my abilities.
It's like a roguelike.
No, no.
There's like a specific...
I know this type... I played this type of game before.
Alright, here you go.
I got you.
Wait, can you open these chests or no?
No, we can't.
Is this DM?
Is this... No, there's like...
There's like an old...
Wait, is this you?
You have to go through or me?
Yeah, it's you.
Oh my god!
There's like an old game that was just like this.
But I don't remember.
It was like an arcade game.
That was just like this.
Alright, give me a sec.
Let me kill this.
Oh.
Nice.
I have to teleport for you.
Okay, you gotta hurry.
You gotta hurry!
I'm getting beat up!
Okay, I got you.
I got you.
I'm good.
Nice.
Okay, I got hit.
Is it gauntlet?
It might be gauntlet.
Cause I remember it looked just like this.
Dude, I have a fucking fire tornado moon.
Wait, how do we...
How do I get over here?
What do you do?
Do you beat this up?
Wait, can I dash through this?
No, I can't.
I'm too fucking...
I can't dash through that.
Is there some way to open that up for me?
You stay right there.
Oh!
I have to go back.
Okay.
I'm too chunky.
Okay, watch this.
Ice.
Don't worry, I got you!
I did it.
Wait, that's you.
I don't have to do anything now.
I don't have to do...
Oh, I might be dying!
Don't die!
Okay, I'm back.
I'm back.
You can die now.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I'll chill here.
Oh, I have to do this.
Woooo!
I think she's dead?
No, there's still one more.
Alright, I gotta kill this one guy.
I believe in you, wife!
Woo!
A fire tornado moon.
Kill him.
Oh, chest.
I feel like the chest is useless.
To be fair.
You have to get them.
Don't worry.
I'm pretty sure your sword can make it over.
There's like range.
This is you.
Yeah, this is you.
This is 100% you.
Come too far.
Yay!
Woo!
Where am I?
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I keep looking at you thinking that's me.
It's okay.
Pew!
Oh!
I accidentally ulted.
Okay.
Freeze!
Don't worry.
The hero is here.
Okay.
It's crazy how many different like genres this game has.
I'm coming over!
I'm helping!
Pew!
Oh, stop.
I didn't look that strong.
I'm coming over!
That's what you get for not believing in my ice powers!
No, I did.
It's just you took too long.
Are you blaming me?
The person that has control here?
With the ices?
I made you a bridge.
And this is the thanks I get?
Okay, fine.
You could have built one before we got tiny.
Huh?
Pew!
Okay.
I'm coming over.
Oh, shit!
What?
What the fuck is that?!
Okay.
We gotta go.
We gotta go fast.
Wait, which way?
It's this way.
I went the wrong way!
I'm not going anywhere.
Me,
me, me!
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me!
I got it, I got it, I got it!
I got it, I got it!
Okay.
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
See, we're okay.
Who the fuck gave this fucking...
baby...
a baby a thing?
Okay.
I got him!
Goodbye!
It's like Toy Story.
Doom!
There's so many references, sis.
Now it's time to kill the queen.
Bowser?
The immortal troll?
The what?
The prisoner!
Wait, he's taking zero damage!
Cause we have to do the chains!
We're not going anywhere!
Yes!
That's it!
We're going to kill the chains!
Okay, I'm going to the chains!
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Okay, I'm going to the chains!
I'm going to the chains!
Bait him here!
Get over here, little man!
Nice.
And then we bait him into the thingy.
We're all toast!
He has to charge it.
Right?
Come on!
Go into the little hole!
Go!
Get his hands!
I'm doing it!
Goodbye, Toy Story!
Yeah!
What she said!
Oh!
Oh me!
Come on!
Over here!
Let's go!
My fire sword is so cool!
Oh!
Doki?
What?
You left!
My game crashed.
It said EA servers.
What?
It says the other player left.
No!
They have to do that again!
The EA servers!
No!
EA!
We have to do dungeon crawler again!
Oh my god!
We just made it!
The curse passed over to you!
Oh, apparently that was a Terminator reference.
Not Doom.
I saw it on Doom though!
Sorry.
Terminator reference.
I remember seeing... Oh!
We did!
We saved!
It saved!
This is my old chess board.
Hey, do you know how to play chess?
Yeah.
I used to be in a chess club.
Because I don't have the time.
Plus it's not a toy.
You know it was my grandmother's.
Oh!
She would appreciate that it's actually being used.
I don't think we're actually playing chess.
Chess board's alive.
There's no way.
What if we don't know how to play chess?
Yes.
We have to kill the king and the queen.
Kill the queen first!
The queen knows the most moves!
That's literally who I'm targeting!
We gotta kill... Wait.
If we kill the king, that means the game ends instantly, right?
Because that's how it should work.
Okay.
I'll go for the king.
I see you.
I'm going for the king.
Wait.
Is it healing?
No.
I'm actually hurting him.
Okay.
That's good.
I was worried.
Don't worry.
I've got this!
We're tag team!
Okay.
Wait.
How did you die?
How did you die though?
It's okay!
The castle can only go in a cross!
I'm teaching you chess.
Hehehehe.
Do you like this little lesson?
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Wait.
Actually, do you know how to play chess?
What the fuck?
I'm going over!
Okay.
That explains why the fucking horses and knights aren't going diagonal.
In L-shape.
Horses don't go diagonal.
They go in an L-shape.
I said in an L-shape!
Hehehehe.
That's why I'm here to teach you about chess.
Mansplainer!
Oh!
Okay.
I don't know.
I didn't get hit once.
Because I know how to play chess.
Why does it have no handles?
I think it's because the queen gets something and shit.
Oh yeah.
You're right.
Oh!
Oh yeah!
I remember!
Haha!
What the fuck?
Did I make this door?
Hehehe.
How?
Yeah.
Oh.
That was not how you opened the door.
No!
We lost our wizard powers!
How are we gonna kill the elephant now?
I don't know.
Wait a minute.
That's right.
I forgot.
I color coded them the opposite way around to fool intruders.
What?
It's actually very smart if you think about it.
Who the fuck's intruders?
Why would you do that?
Who's gonna intrude the castle?
Haha.
Oh.
Still gonna miss my outfit.
Oh my god.
Why do we put electricity there?
Like, for a kid's toy?
What if my daughter forgot?
Yeah.
She's gonna shock her finger.
Greetings, your majesty.
Hello.
You don't need to bow.
I'm Cutie the elephant.
Oh my gosh.
She's so cute.
Do you want some cookies?
I actually love cookies.
Cody, you're not here to stuff your face with cookies.
Let's just do this.
You sound unhappy.
You can tell me what's wrong.
That's what friends are for.
No, no.
Nothing's wrong.
It's great.
Everything's like super great.
Well, I can see you're not happy.
You need a hug.
I kinda do.
Aww.
What are you doing?
Let's kill her.
Woah.
No, no, no.
We don't wanna kill you.
We just kinda have to.
It's a little bit.
But we're cutie the loving elephant.
Oh my god.
Aww.
What the fuck is wrong with you, Goomy?
I know.
You're the one that said it.
You were like, we're gonna kill her.
And I was like, woah.
No, you made this plan.
No, no, no.
This is a group effort.
When we get married...
You keep saying that.
When we got married, every idea is a group effort.
There's no I in marriage.
Why the fuck does she keep turning around to look back at us?
Oh my god.
To the moon!
Oh my god!
Do you see that?
See that?
The drawing on the box!
Oh yeah!
There's Elmo!
Oh my god!
Where was she?
Oh!
Guess that's the way the cookie crumbles.
Well that's fucked up, Goomy.
Oh, it's like the cookie monster!
We don't want to do this, but we have to!
We have to make Rose cry!
It's nothing personal!
See, you said it!
No, no, no.
You said it first.
I just went with you.
I just enabled you.
No.
Oh, it's a crane game!
I'm really good at this!
Man, always changing the narrative.
Whoa.
No, that's not it.
We have to...
You have to...
Okay, I'll do the grabby thing.
I'll do the grabby thing.
I made a fucking claw machine for her?
Bro, I'm the perfect dad.
Holy shit.
Okay, we need to time this better.
Okay, she's got...
She goes in a circle.
Yeah, she goes in a fucking circle.
Okay, we wait here.
Okay.
One, two, three.
No, no, no, no, no!
Why did you move?
Perfectly!
Okay.
You put it over here.
Okay, okay.
And I'll time it.
Watch this.
Maybe we go up here because I'm impatient.
Maybe here.
I'm impatient.
Boom!
There you go.
Perfect timing.
Oh my god!
That is so fucked up.
Oh my god.
How are we gonna kill this thing?
You know how Yusa looks like a cookie monster?
Yeah.
It kinda reminds me of those old YouTube videos.
Oh, like, let me fire my laser.
Yeah!
Let me fire my laser.
I don't wanna do this.
I think her head's gonna pop off.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, this head is definitely gonna pop off.
I think we're popping off her head.
Oh!
At least it's not the head.
We gotta get her to the edge of the bookshelf.
Edge of the bookshelf?
Come on!
Grab her!
Bro, this is...
Bro, where's your guard?
Alright, let's go.
It's time to take her to the edge.
Come on, Gumi.
We already made it this far.
We can't back up now!
We made it this far!
It's alright.
Oh, god.
They're begging to not die.
Oh, my god.
She's struggling!
Get her!
She can't get away!
My god.
Who did I marry?
I married a boy of hers.
It's too late!
We're already this far!
If we let her live, she's gonna tell the cops!
Stop resisting!
Pump!
She doesn't need the ear!
She doesn't feel no...
She doesn't feel pain!
Don't worry!
She feels zero pain!
She's a dog!
Down she goes!
Goodbye!
See?
She was lying about feeling pain!
Gumi, come on.
No, you can button mash faster than this, Gumi.
Come on!
This is a group effort!
We agreed to this when we got married!
I don't want to!
I did agree to committing murder!
Lord, lift the king!
...
We just...
Dude, imagine being a kid!
Imagine being a kid and seeing your doll ripped up out of nowhere!
I like how we...
I love how we threw her leg and ears to...
Cry.
Oh no, cutie.
Poor cutie.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry you hurt yourself.
What?
...
Success.
We made it look like an accident.
I'm sorry.
May, I think it's working.
...
Don't we need her tears, though?
Yes!
Come on!
Alright, we gotta get down there!
Quick!
Before she stops!
This way!
Come on!
This is so fucked up.
Like, this is the part where it's fucked up.
Imagine parents hogging.
Yeah, like, our kids cried!
Fuck yeah!
Woohoo!
Time to dance in the rain!
Let's go!
Dance!
Sweets!
Sweet tears!
Woo!
Yeah!
Shower time!
...
God, you read so fucking slow!
Maybe we just never have kids, though.
What?!
That did not look like four pieces, man.
Yeah, that's a big ass letter.
What?!
Bro, fuck this book!
Are we just gonna ignore the fact that we could...
Do we make a fucking kid cry?
Yeah, we're gonna ignore the fact that she's crying?
Yeah, we're... oh yeah, you're right, we don't need the top two.
We already read the top two.
Oh, we're in therapy.
I told you we needed couples counseling.
You refer to us instead of me.
You're a team now.
I know we're not a team and we don't have time for this.
Time?
Good man.
That will be our first topic.
Aha!
Now, do you give each other enough time?
See, that's crazy, but...
We actually... we don't.
Yeah, we don't.
She is never at home.
Yeah, you love your job more than you love me.
I'm working for both of us.
I'm working too.
You don't even make money.
But I make sacrifices.
It is!
It's...
No, it's not!
Look, we made progress.
Look at that!
We made progress!
I think that couples therapy is working.
I don't want to go to therapy anymore.
I think it's over.
I've checked out.
I can't believe you're right.
My chat was like, I sacrificed my bowel pass for you.
Like, that's how deep my love is.
That I paid for!
That we share a bank account.
It's our money.
Because I'm the only one working.
Wow!
And got it!
With no sense of time, you will now be able to control that!
I do!
I got the power!
Whoa!
Oh, you have the clone.
I have time.
What's this?
Is that me?
God.
Why am I so old?
Where's your hairline?
Look at that.
Look how far your hairline goes.
It's a style.
It's a choice.
God, you sound like...
Because I...
That's me.
Because you might as well be.
Okay, then he used the bathtub for a prank.
Don't be weird to my chat.
I don't need to follow those wooden dolls.
The book says we have to make the two meet.
So what?
Let's just do it.
We need Rose's letter to break the spell.
Chat, I'm going to tell you guys a story.
Oh, what story should I tell?
What?
What story have I not talked about in a while?
That Doki chat probably hasn't heard.
Maybe the OGs.
I don't know.
What do I have?
I didn't know they made a plush of it.
I think...
When I was younger...
I had a nightmare.
This is completely unrelated.
I just thought about the paste-eating kid from Powerpuff Girls.
But when I was younger, I used to have a lot of nightmares about this one specific episode that had a mime in it.
And like...
I think...
No!
Actually, no!
This reminded me!
I actually have a good story.
So when I was in third grade...
Second, third grade...
I kept having nightmares.
They were recurring nightmares...
Of my mom driving...
And abandoning me...
At a trailer park with the Kanker sisters.
From Ed, Edd, and Eddy.
And it would be different each time.
Like the first time I had it, she just abandoned me there.
The second time...
They abandoned me there, but my like...
Step-sister removed was in the car.
And then in the third one...
She abandoned me there.
But they...
They started shooting...
Fucking ARs.
They had ARs and everything and I had to take cover behind a couch.
I was like hiding behind a couch like this.
So scared.
And like you can see the bullet holes through the couch.
Anyways...
My teacher gave us an assignment.
That was like...
Write down...
Your dreams...
Of late...
Like...
Your dreams of lately.
And I wrote that down and then they pulled me aside like...
Is everything okay, Crystal?
I'm like yeah.
I mean...
I don't know when I'm gonna have that dream again, but it's okay.
Anyways...
What the fuck kind of dream was that?
What the fuck?
It was an occurring dream.
A recurring dream?
What?
Are you okay?
I don't know.
That's second grade me, man.
That was second grade, dog.
That's second grade?
So I saw the...
I saw the Goomy Teen.
Guys, this is what the Goomy Teen looks like.
So...
The...
It's basically a skin.
It's a Fortnite skin.
You put a fucking DLC skin on top of a guillotine.
That's...
Okay.
Don't you see those people who trademark their own special knives and shit?
No.
It's still...
What?
It's still a knife.
And then they name it something else?
What do you mean?
Yeah, but they name it something else.
Okay, I fixed it.
There you go.
I fixed it.
It's your turn to fix this.
Wait, what's...
What happened?
Oh, did you not make it through?
You have to time it.
Oh, I thought I...
I thought you made it through.
I made it through.
There you go.
I got the cool powers.
Wait, what's your power?
I can make clones of myself.
Oh, I think you can make a clone of yourself here.
Oh, wait.
You have to make clones to do the lever.
No, no, no.
I go back in time.
What?
Wait, what?
Hey, maybe you can reach the door before it closes with your clone.
Yeah, see?
Oh, I thought you meant you want me to leave it to the lever.
No, no.
I want you to have your clone to go over there.
Bing.
Yay!
What's this?
Oh!
No, I have...
Yeah, yeah, hook onto this.
Hook...
Wait.
What?
Where are you bringing it?
Oh, no.
Oh, here, here, here.
And then...
I make it go up here?
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
We're so smart.
We're so fucking smart.
Who designed this?
Oh, shit!
Wait, do I respawn next to you?
Oh, no, I don't.
I should be able to make it.
Make this jump.
Yay!
You have to do the time thingy over there.
Where?
Oh, here.
I'm rewinding.
Right here it is.
Oh, shit.
Jump.
Not that thingy.
No, it's this.
That's the only thing I can rewind.
No, look over there.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Oh!
I did it.
Wait, but where would you go?
Oh.
Yeah, that's the thing.
Where do you go?
There's a button up there.
Must be...
I think you jump over there.
Yeah.
I think I did it.
I did it.
Wait, what?
And then what?
And then you leave your clothes?
Hold on.
Yeah, let it fall.
Oh!
We did it!
And then I'll let it go up?
Uh huh.
Yeah.
And then you press the button!
Team!
I like how you said we did it, but I figured it out.
Yeah, but you need me to be able to do it.
We're able to do it!
There's no I in team!
There's no I in marriage too!
There we go.
Fixed it.
What do we do with this?
Why did you fix it?
Nothing.
Oh, but it looks so beautiful.
We needed this thing.
Oh, this.
Not this.
I can't... what?
There's only one I can pull.
I can't pull the other thing.
That's why I think I have to do this.
Yeah, see?
I told you!
That's what it fixes!
Oh, the owl waited now!
Yeah, and then... whoop!
We get launched over and then I send you back up.
And then you leave your clone and then I go away.
And then you clone.
And then I go...
And then you go up.
See?
I feel like a little rat.
Rat, rat.
We are the rats.
There we go!
And then we just go here.
Yay!
Oh!
I accidentally pressed A.
It's an accident.
What?
Hahaha!
I agreed with you.
I said, sure!
God!
Qua?
Gaslighting.
Pretty usual.
I'm gaslighting?
I said sch...
I agreed with you.
I...
Why are you pressing?
Oh, they're like cuckoo clocks.
We have to leave.
Do you have to leave your clone?
Wait, you have to leave your clone on one of them, maybe?
Yeah.
Yeah, cause like...
Yeah, then you go back.
There you go.
Rewind that shit.
I'm rewinding?
Yeah, rewinding.
Don't you have to...
Oh, can you not rewind and stand on it?
No, I think you have to stand...
No.
What the hell?
Whoa!
This is like...
Seampunk.
Is.
This.
Who built this?
I did.
Because no one else is gonna take credit.
I'll take credit for it.
You didn't even let me have a chance.
You just said it in a split second.
I'll be honest.
If you really wanted to take credit for it, you'd be faster.
I didn't want to take credit for something that I didn't do.
Yeah, cause I did it.
Did that book say anything about what we do if we lose the track of those guys?
No, he was just blabbing on and on about time.
Oh yeah.
I built it, smile.
Yeah.
Why are you not home?
Huh?
Is it cause of Jerry at work?
Who the fuck is Jerry?
What does he have that I don't?
A job.
Being a house husband is a job.
How fucking dare you?
I changed her diapers.
I also changed her diapers.
No you didn't.
I come home, you're asleep on the couch.
You went to do engineer stuff.
I'm a...
I go to work.
I'm working hard.
I come home, you're sleeping on the couch and she's doing her homework alone in the room and I still have dishes to do.
No, I cleaned the dishes.
Why do you leave the dishes?
I did.
I totally cleaned the dishes.
It's not my fault that you use all the dishes.
I did.
Like do you really need to use...
Why don't we have paper plates?
Sorry.
You have to leave her clone I think, right?
There.
Yeah.
What?
Why didn't you press it?
No I did.
We have to wait.
Gotta keep following those dolls.
Look at these clock people.
Wait, what is over here?
What the fuck is over here?
Where is this other area?
This area is fucking...
Oh I found it!
I already found the other bell.
I think that was just a regular bell.
I found the regular bell.
This is actually beautiful.
Yay!
Game!
Game?
Where is that?
Mom?
I'm trying to find you right now.
Jesus Christ.
This is a huge area.
The hell tower?
Holy fuck.
We taught our kid the word hell?
What the fuck?
How do we play this?
Follow the bubbles and reach the finish line.
What?
I thought this was just a bubble.
Oh it's like spiral where we have to follow the thing.
Oh man.
Run and you won't explode me.
Okay.
Check.
Stay on track Cody.
Come on.
This is not fair.
Why are you faster?
I will not explode.
This is not fair.
What are you doing to me?
We got the same speed!
You got a head start.
No you have the head start.
You're faster than me.
There's no other reason.
I will not explode.
Oh god.
I'm coming over!
Where does it go?
Nice.
Oh, this way, this way, this way.
This way, this way, this way.
I did it!
Yes!
Whoa!
Yeah!
Not a cope anymore!
Cause I won.
Oh, the artichoke.
Oh god, I think I need to eat another tub.
Not a cope.
Wait, there's another game over here!
There's another game over here!
Follow me!
Hey.
Yeah!
Yay!
Wait, where are you, Gumi?
There's a game right over here!
The chickens!
What is this?
Oh, it's a shooter!
Did you call the sheep chicken?
No, there's a chicken next to the horse!
There you go.
Get on the horse.
I'm ready.
Oh god.
Okay.
Crouch.
Avoid obstacles to reach the finish line.
Crouch and jump.
Alright.
Not against my winning horse.
How do I crouch?
Like, is it pressing?
It said it.
Oh, it's like this!
Wee-oh!
Yay!
Wave!
Oh my god, look how beautiful my horse is.
Wee!
Did I be honest?
Yeah.
I like the horses that look like they're wearing socks.
You know what I mean?
Oh, I know what you mean.
Yeah.
They're really fancy.
No!
It's not fair!
Best race ever!
What do you mean it's not fair?
When I don't win, it's not fair.
Because
of your horse!
Your horse, Comet!
Sounds intriguing.
Your horse, Comet, distracted me!
How are you missing?
I don't know.
I'm stupid.
Whoa!
Is this part of the game?
Is this...
What the... It kind of reminds me of Bayonetta.
Ooh, it reminds me of that cheap game.
You know that one?
Catherine?
Oh my god!
I've always wanted to play Catherine.
I can play Catherine!
I wonder if Catherine will be a good game this stream.
I've always wanted to play that game.
It's always been like super interesting.
Whoa... No!
Damn it!
I fell on Hell Tower!
Can you do this for... wait, do I have to be there?
Can you just... can you just...
Oh, I fell!
Oh, okay.
I thought you could do it for me.
I fell too.
Oh my god, this is truly is hell.
Is this even worth it?
I don't think this is part of the game.
I feel like this is not mandatory.
There's no way that this is mandatory.
Dude, why is it so hard up there?
Oh my god!
Are we just bad?
Are we just bad at video games?
There's no way.
I thought we were gamers.
What happened?
Well, I'm at the wall jump part.
Okay, I can just...
Okay, I'm scared.
How do we wall jump here?
Oh god.
No, that was scary.
No!
Do we have to...
Oh my god.
I hate how this moves.
No!
You distracted me!
I can't believe it.
You distracted me.
I did do nothing.
I can't believe you would do this to me.
I can't... I give up.
I'm...
This is not part of the game.
This is not...
It is part of the game!
No, it's not!
There's no way!
This is not part of the story!
I'm gonna fish.
There's a fishing.
Let's just fish.
I don't...
I'm gonna fish and you go do your fucking thing.
I gotta catch!
Wait, what the fuck?
Why couldn't I catch it?
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Come on.
Husband's gotta bring in a juicy fish.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna feed the family.
Come on, come on.
The most exciting gameplay is right here!
Oh!
I got a catch!
Are you happy?
Look!
I got us some food.
Oh my god!
Look!
I got more food!
I told you it didn't matter!
It was just fireworks!
I got us fish though.
Wow, look at that.
I can't even see the fireworks.
I can't even see it from here.
You have to...
Oh, there you are.
I see it now.
So beautiful.
I am the real gamer.
It's okay.
I caught us some fish.
Like a good husband.
I provided food on the table.
The Hell Tower does not provide food.
That's all I'm saying.
It provides joy.
Something that you didn't bring.
To the table.
Wow!
I'm the fun dad!
I built the castle!
Oh, so we need to move the clouds.
You have to move the clouds somehow.
How do we move the clouds?
It must be something you have to do because...
Because like I just rewind time and then the rain falls down.
Why are you guys freaking out?
It's not like it's your house, right?
This guy is dancing.
Look at him go.
He's dancing.
He doesn't care.
Where is it?
I don't know.
I have no idea where it could be.
How do you move it?
No, that's not it.
Don't worry.
I got this.
My magic power.
Dad power.
Yay!
Rain!
We need that.
Yeah.
And then...
There you go.
They're happy now.
I don't think that person is dancing.
I think they were asking for help.
No, no.
Look at him.
Look at him dance.
He's dancing.
He's having a great time.
Whee!
Just like me.
I'll grab this one.
Oh, he's fishing too.
Look at him go.
Can I fish with him?
Oh, there's a timer here.
Oh, shit.
That's dangerous.
Okay, I have to do this.
Oh, we have to...
We have to...
Go back.
Okay, okay.
We have to do this again.
And then I have to...
Snag it.
I fucking... I fucked up.
Wait.
I fucked up.
Hey, come back.
Come back.
Okay.
I messed up a little.
Just a little.
What the fuck?
Just a little bit.
I made one simple mistake.
Every dad gets one.
Oh, I think you've had more than one.
This is my one.
There you go.
Look at that go.
Yeah, that's me.
That's me.
Oh, they're lumberjacking.
Where are they going?
To the clock.
This is our mansion?
Open.
Where's the clock tower?
Now, to just open this gate.
Why did we open it?
Why?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Match.
Make it match.
Oh, wait.
Which...
I'm the tiny one.
I did it.
Doki is the one who held this marriage.
What do you mean?
I am the glue to this marriage.
Without me, this marriage will fall apart.
Yeah.
Without me, I provide...
I provide for this family.
Oh, no.
I even bought us paper plates, so we...
I'm working two jobs for us.
I even bought us paper plates, so we don't have to waste water.
Oh my God, you remind me of my old roommate.
So we don't have to waste water.
See, we're saving water bills.
We're saving water bills by not...
Is that why you haven't showered in three weeks?
is that why you haven't showered in three weeks?
Is that where we're going?
You don't know that.
but to get inside...
I can smell it.
I have clones.
The clone!
The clone doesn't do enough.
He thinks I'm right!
I told you time doesn't matter!
Oh my god!
Hold on!
Did you know?
Not did you know, but like...
My friend has a little sibling.
Yeah?
Who's... I think 19 now?
And...
He like... leaves...
a little strawberry toothpaste.
He leaves a little toothpaste on his little sibling's toothbrush.
To check if their sibling brushes their teeth.
What?
Apparently, the toothpaste has not disappeared.
It's been leaked.
Oh my god!
They can't!
That's disgusting!
I know!
Where are you going?
Okay, I'll go to the left then.
But these aren't machines!
I'm gonna go to the left.
Wait, what do we do?
Oh, we have to be at the same one.
Come here!
We have to be at the same one?
Look at that tower!
We might be able to land on it.
Okay.
I thought we had to separate.
It's fine.
I'm good at flying.
Look at me go.
Don't worry.
Your hero is here.
I'm trying to figure out how to get off.
Look at that.
First try.
Did the dad make this?
Yeah, I made this.
Why is there any castle here?
Turns out that sibling of my friend's also like...
Oh yeah!
That's a good thing.
I think they just went to shower because they just wanted to play games.
What the f- Oh, so he's a NEET!
He's like, wait, I think this is a puzzle.
I don't think we know the answer yet, right?
Do...
Do sun.
Why?
Yeah, I don't think we know the answer yet.
I think we have to figure it out here.
But like...
We don't know the answer.
Oh, but...
What the hell?
Is that sculpture?
Oh shit.
What does he want?
Oh, come back.
Whoa!
How do I get to the other side?
Oh, okay!
Hold on.
Oh, you have... okay.
Oh, thank god you're on that side and I'm doing this.
Okay, B.
B first.
B.
Okay.
Bird.
Cat.
Moon.
Dog.
Sun.
We did it!
Yay!
Woo!
Hello.
It's your beautiful husband.
What?
Because you marry me for my looks.
And charm.
Yeah.
We did it!
Wait, what?
How else did you marry me?
Are we gonna bomb the castle?
Oh, yeah.
What's wrong with this game and boss?
We're gonna bomb in our little kid's place.
I think they're trying to teach us how to make...
I think we can use them.
What?
Is this a blimeral messaging?
Suddenly, we want to blow castles up.
All right, my bird.
Wee!
Don't worry, I'm not on the list.
Because I'm not American.
Wee!
I'm not American.
All right, I'm here.
I made it before you did.
But I can't get off my bird.
My bird won't let me.
How did you get off the bird?
My bird likes me.
Oh, okay, I did it.
I had to wait for you to get off the bird.
No, you did not.
It's because my bird likes me too much.
So she doesn't want me to get off.
I think it's because I had control of my bird.
Goodbye.
Why is it...
It's because it's on green now.
You have to wait.
Yeah, see?
Yeah, you should have waited.
Why did you jump then?
Because I'm a little special.
Mommy says I'm a special little girl.
You're pissing me off.
Here, I made the bridge back.
Here.
How do you go down this bridge?
Do I?
Yeah.
Because it goes on the red first.
There.
What did you do?
I changed the red to blue.
Oh, you changed it.
Oh, okay.
Oh my gosh, this takes so long.
Wait, oh.
No, why did you do that?
I didn't think you were ready.
I was ready.
Jump on a red.
I did it.
You have to make it red again.
Why did you have to make it red again?
It goes green.
You're yelling at me.
Oh, no.
I just said don't do well with negative reinforcements.
I don't...
I had too much negative reinforcements!
Do you know what you're doing?
Yeah, I just... I'll be honest.
What do I do?
There we go, we did it.
We did it!
You're pissing me off.
Yay!
I think it's fully stopped.
Like the thing.
So like it won't turn anything else.
Yeah.
Trust me.
Yeah, see jump through it.
What are you doing?
I don't trust you.
Oh.
Okay, and then...
What are you doing?
You didn't trust me!
I can tell you didn't trust me there!
There you go.
Yay!
You're right, I didn't trust you.
Alright.
I'm spinning, spinning, spinning, spinning, spinning.
Spinning, spinning.
Wow!
What the heck is that?
A force field?
Yeah.
Wait, what do we do now?
Where's our crows?
Oh!
There we are.
I will never forget you, crow.
Well, you didn't see anything!
You died.
Oh wow!
Why can't it go through the force field?
Because I don't think it can.
I don't think we've like... we didn't force it enough.
Wait, we have to...
Oh, I know what we have to do.
What do we have to do?
Let's see what you can do!
Oh!
Wait, where did...
You get it from the sky, man!
Oh, the sky!
Oh my god!
I got the bomb.
Aim.
Oh, okay.
I just aim and throw.
Oh, okay!
I figured it out.
The controller is...
I killed mine!
I killed mine too!
I literally see it alive.
Look, I'm shooting it from here.
See, I told you I killed mine!
I told you I did it.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Oh, I'm here.
Yay!
Why are they stuck down there?
I have to rewind.
Because I need to bring them back up.
There you go.
Yay!
And then...
And then what?
Go in!
Is there something we have to do?
What do we have to do?
We need something.
What the fuck?
Oh, maybe...
Oh, you have to get the wall jump to the other side.
I like my bird.
Gumi, you have to wall jump to the other side.
Gumi, I'm literally doing this right now.
I like my bird.
We can take the bird home after.
That's cool.
I like this.
I like this mechanism.
Yay!
Woo!
I like my bird.
You lied to me.
I don't like that sound.
Do we really have to follow them?
Yes!
We'll never get out of here.
Fine.
Ladies first.
What the fuck?
I'm a gentleman.
I'm letting you go first.
See?
We both were to drop down anyway.
May!
May, is that wall moving?
Yes!
What?
Oh shit.
I built this.
There's nowhere to run!
Why did I build this?
May!
May, do something!
What?
Me?
You do something!
Yeah, you do something!
Someone help!
Uh...
Hurry up!
Wait, what did you do?
I almost thought we wouldn't make it.
Almost?
I was a genius, that's why.
I know what you did!
We made it!
You put a clone on the other side!
Oh my god, look!
Tiny rats!
They're not tiny rats!
Oh my god, look at these rats!
Rats!
Tiny rats!
We are the rats!
Okay, time to rewind.
You're playing a suck at night here, a rat.
Where are we opening?
Oh, we're closing the door.
No, we're going up.
Yeah, we close the door and go up.
Both things can happen, Gumi!
You can multitask!
Look, there's a door!
There's us!
What a magnificent place!
Yeah!
Oh my god, it's so beautiful!
It's full of medical parts!
With no real functionality!
I get this smile.
This place is beautiful, but it doesn't make any sense!
Why do you always have to make sense of everything?
Yeah!
Someone has to!
And I know it's not you!
Someone has to?
Baby, you can't explain every little thing that happens in life!
You need a fun dad!
I need one in general!
We all know the good cop is the dad!
The bad cop is the dad and the bad cop is the mom!
What?
I'm the fun dad!
So, like, when our daughter is mad, she yells at you and then when she wants to have fun, she goes to me!
It's like typical parenting!
I don't like the look of that guy!
Oh, that's supposedly normal!
It's so normal!
The dad takes you out to have fun and have...
The gatekeeper!
What the fuck?
Wait, what?
Bro, what the fuck is that?
Wait, where do we supposed to go?
I'm going here.
I don't know where I am.
Go, go!
Where am I?
Where are you?
Wait, I think we went on the wrong area!
Okay, I'm going back to you!
What do you mean, we went on the wrong area?
We went on the wrong side.
I don't know.
Oh my god, it's a Keyblade!
I'm here.
Holy what?
Woah, are you okay?
Woah!
I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
Fun Dad's coming.
Hello, sweetie.
Fun Dad is here.
Are we sure this is the right way?
Are you sure?
I feel like we're supposed to...
REWIND IT!
I can't reach!
Oh, I could.
Okay.
Yay.
There we go.
And then you have to put your clone.
And then...
Ta-da!
And then we go this way.
And then clone time.
I'm glad I'm the time person so I can do less work.
Oh.
I'm glad this is where I'm at.
Alright.
And then...
We can do it higher up here, right?
eta
Where does this turn?
Okay.
And then where does this turn?
Nowhere you had to go.
Where you had to go from here?
You've turned it.
I'm turning, I'm turning, I'm turning, I'm turning!
Oh I think I turn too fast.
Where are you supposed to go?
Wait, wait, wait!
Wait!
At least you don't have to do it all the way.
Where are you?
Oh, you're here.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Oh, I can't see.
I hate this camera angle.
Okay.
Ready?
Are you ready?
Just drop down.
Here, see?
And then I just turn.
And I just turn.
You just have to run with the thing.
Okay, then what?
I've turned the wrong way.
Sorry.
That's what I thought.
Wait, and then what?
How do you get to the other side?
I guess you put your clone?
You put your clone or something?
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait!
I see it.
Yeah, but you have to...
You can't get there.
There's no way you can get there.
You have to put your clone.
Put my clone where?
I don't know.
Somewhere.
Why do you turn it without saying anything?
You can look at the visuals!
I'm lucky to see how we get there!
Okay, I turned it.
Maybe put a clone here.
Clone where?
Just where you're standing.
Yeah, see?
No, not now!
What do you even see?
Okay, just put that here.
And now I want to keep turning.
Because it gets closer!
When I turn it, you see that?
It gets closer.
I don't think my clone moves with it, does it?
No, like the thingy turns.
The thingy gets closer.
What thingy?
So like, okay.
So if I turn it all the way to the other side...
It like gets closer.
Like the other thing gets closer.
Doesn't it?
You're pissing me off.
I'm so confused.
I'm confused.
My brain hurts.
It turned this way the entire time?
And you just stopped turning it?
We did it!
Oh my god, we did it!
Why did you stop turning it?
I'm so proud of us!
I thought there was a limit to how much you could turn!
We did it!
Yay!
Woo!
We did it!
Yay!
Oh my god.
Get over here.
Wait, I thought we had to do one ear.
Oh.
Okay, I'll turn the key?
Okay, I'm coming back to turn the key.
It's time to turn the keyblade.
Here you go.
Hey, come back.
What are you doing?
Don't you want to turn the key?
No, I don't want to turn the key.
Why not?
Fun Dad does it again!
Makes fun for everybody!
See?
I'm here to make this a fun, enjoyable time for all the kids to enjoy.
I'm turning it.
Oh!
I think we have to go back.
Not here, but like back here.
Because there's another time thing here.
See that?
And then there's another one here too.
I think I have to do the wall thing here.
And then I do this.
Okay, and then I do this.
Isn't it great?
I can just sit back and relax.
Alright, and then...
Here you go.
And then...
Let me know when you're ready to do that.
Now you have to jump.
For this.
Okay, you ready?
Okay, I'm ready.
Yeah!
Fun Dad does it again!
There you go.
Let me know...
Boom!
And then...
Burn.
Wait till I get lower first?
Okay.
Yeah!
I know we did it!
Oh, what the fuck?
What happened?
I just died.
Rewind it, rewind it.
I was too close.
Wait, what?
I rewind it.
How do we...
Do I have to be under it?
No, that doesn't seem right.
Yeah, it doesn't seem right.
How do we cut this?
Well, we cut it already.
Yeah, but how do we get inside?
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait.
Bring it back up?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh!
You're so smart!
You're so smart, wife.
Stop!
Okay, there we go.
Bring it...
Wait.
Yeah.
Boom!
We did it!
See?
Teamwork!
Fun dad, fun dad.
Let's go.
Alright.
What did...
Oh, do we have to turn it together?
Are that...
No, like we both have to turn one of it together, right?
Yeah, cause I can't.
I'm too weak.
Fun dad is a little flabby.
Oh!
Where do we...
The key.
Is this the key?
Oh, and then we... the other one turns it down.
Alright.
Here we go.
And we do this.
Yeah!
Oh, shit.
We did it!
Who the fuck's making this shit?
How... we... we haven't even finished one chapter yet, I feel like.
We did!
We finished the... We finished the Princess Cutie chapter!
That was a chapter?
Yeah...
Oh my god!
What is that?
I don't know!
What's going on?
Oh my god!
Oh god, how do we kill this?
Wait, wait, wait.
There's a time in here.
Distract him!
I don't think the bull cares, Cody!
Oh!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I need you to lead the bull right here!
Lead him right here, I think.
Hey, maybe you can trick him with your clone!
Yes, trick him with your clone!
That stone plate looks like it could hurt it!
Yeah!
Is he gonna go there?
Oh, it's gonna charge!
Wait, what?
What?
Where are you charging?
Oh!
Me!
Oh, fuck!
I'm dead.
Bro, what the fuck?
Okay, I don't have to be next to it to do this.
Put your clone!
Put your clone over there!
Oh, fuck!
It's me again!
Okay.
You have to put your clone over there!
Stinky shit!
Shut up!
Watch out, me!
Okay.
He's distracted.
I got it.
He doesn't see me.
Yeah!
We got him!
We did it!
Hey, I got it!
Just a couple more hits, okay?
He doesn't see me.
Guys, I don't think he saw me.
Ow!
It's okay.
He didn't see me.
I can stand here.
Yeah!
Wait, what?
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
What?
It's fine?
Ow, it's fine.
Ow!
Give me a sec.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
He doesn't see me.
Here you go.
I can stand here.
Yay!
Bow down!
He can stand?
I should have done it!
Okay.
Oh, I got body stabbed!
Why me?
I'm not ready!
What did I do?
Don't come near me!
I'm not ready!
I can't even see!
I did it!
It's okay.
Thank you for the bait.
You're pissing me off!
You left the club there!
I did it.
That was a tough one.
I'm exhausted!
Yay!
We better keep moving!
Come on!
I did it!
I'm so proud of us!
Oh god!
Yay!
Hard work!
So hard, I know, right?
Cody understands the hard work of this marriage.
I wonder if like...
Can you ward?
Oh, you can!
But like, why would you?
I think we have to ward...
Ward jump this, right?
Do we?
Why else would like...
I'm so confused.
Why is it like that?
Hello, wife.
I need... I need to eat a thumbs.
I don't understand.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, do it.
Um...
That's why I don't think so.
What?
This doesn't make sense.
What the fuck do we do?
Okay, I gotta help you ward jump.
How do I help you ward jump though?
Um...
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Okay.
I'm making it close.
I'm making this easier for you.
Yay!
You make...
Fun dad.
I wanna divorce immediately.
Oh, I gotta stand up here.
And then go...
...
Fun dad's coming over.
And then go...
Here I am.
Here we go.
We did it.
I think I have to...
I think, um...
Hey.
I think you have to come back here.
Why?
Because I need you to stand on the button so I can put my clone there.
And stand on the button so you can get over.
So we both can get over.
Oh!
Wait, you're not over?
I can't!
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
Don't worry.
Daddy's coming over.
Cause daddy's home for me.
Here he goes.
Okay,
now you can go.
Yay!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Look,
there's...
Oh, we met up together!
Look!
We're back, we're okay now!
Now, kiss.
Oh, what?
Oh!
Hey, what's this?
We just jump over?
Oh, I guess we just jump over.
What if I just...
Oh!
Don't stand in the center!
I don't think I was planning on it.
It's Mario Party.
It's the jump rope.
Watch this 360.
Is this hot?
No!
I knew that!
Wait, it's...
The chest is not even stopped there!
What the fuck?
I was relying on you to say a lot so I can fuck around!
But look at this 360 there.
Whoa!
That 360 sucks.
I'm good.
I'm okay.
Let's go.
Yay!
360 no scope!
Wow!
You're doing really well!
Oh, thank you, Gumi!
I'm like a poker stick!
I can't wait for the voice papers to come through.
Thank you, Gumi.
I know I'm doing really well.
Wow!
Guys, I'm so...
I'm what the kids say.
Pog!
Ew!
I learned that on the Tiki Talk yesterday.
You hear about the...
There's like... I was watching this video about this dad.
That's like some fucking...
Skateboarder or some shit.
Some extreme fucking...
No!
Breakdancer!
Yeah!
This guy left his family to be a professional breakdancer.
Oh my god!
Yeah!
And he like makes really cringy TikToks and shit.
I was watching like...
A video like about talking about this fucking dad that was like a professional breakdancer.
And he left his family and his career because he wanted to be a professional breakdancer.
And he's like 50 or some shit.
Where do I go?
It sounds like you.
Oh, they got a divorce?
Oh my god!
They got a divorce just to be a professional.
Of course.
But not really.
I'm about to be us, baby!
I'm gonna be a professional breakdancer!
Yeah!
Wait, his daughter lied?
Mom, can I stay with you?
Dad is being cringy.
Wait, but...
The daughter lied for...
He paid millions in the divorce?
Oh my god!
But didn't he...
Okay, but like did he want a divorce because of breakdancing?
Or because of...
Or just because he hates his wife?
Like...
Like which one?
Is it...
Does he hate his wife?
Or like he wanted to be a breakdancer?
He was a great dad?
He was and only took breakdance 20 years.
That is just a hobby.
The wife was bad.
Okay.
Damn!
I can't believe the daughter lied on the internet on TikTok.
I don't know what's going on, man.
The mom divorced him?
No way!
I can't believe the daughter lied.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he lied on the internet.
I'm so fucking like...
I'm so like registering the fact that...
The daughter lied about his break...
Her breakdancing dad.
I don't know what's going on.
I haven't seen the breakdancing dad, man.
Bro!
He was on like America's Got Talent.
I don't know if he actually was on America's Got Talent.
He invented its nest!
Keep your eyes on it!
But he apparently breakdanced professionally.
Whoa!
Bird!
That was close!
I am freaking out!
Oh my god!
Whoa!
Once again, we're running out of real estate!
I can't believe it.
People lie on TikTok like that?
I'm so registering the fact that...
breakdancing dad was never...
breakdancing dad story was a lie.
He's a really good breakdancer.
You should look him up.
I'm not going to look up breakdancing dad, man.
Why not?
He's a good...
He won like trophies!
You just don't like dads in general.
Are you talking to me?
You don't like fun dads.
I took hip hop dance classes in college!
You just don't like fun dads.
You're right.
Because I think they're overcompensating for something.
It's not actual fun.
It's fake fun though.
IT'S FUN!
EVERYBODY ENJOYS DOKI, DAD!
Not everyone.
That's why this marriage will never work.
You don't appreciate fun, dad.
I think that's why I wanted a divorce in the first place.
You used to like fun, dad.
You used to love it.
What happened?
I don't think I ever liked fun, dad.
You only became a dad after we had a kid, man.
You used to love fun, dad.
It was so fun.
There's... nothing.
We just like... where do we go?
Oh.
We can just stand in the center.
I like how we just move like a little bit.
We don't have to like move too far, which is nice.
I think they really wanted us to stress out this game.
We did it.
Yay!
Luigi wins by doing nothing!
Oh.
Down we go.
Oh, it's like the... the Disneyland.
Like the... the...
The Tower... Hotel Tower thing.
Oh, dude.
I hated that ride.
I never got to ride it.
I was too young.
I haven't been to Disneyland in so fucking long.
You wanna go?
Which one, though?
I'm thinking... I'm thinking...
We can get a...
Well...
Which one's the best one?
Wanna go to Tokyo Sea?
Okay, I actually... I'm not... I don't know.
Cause like Tokyo Sea... I've actually been to Tokyo Sea, but I was like 10 or some shit.
What is happening?
We're rewinding.
We can do this again.
I like how we're just having a casual conversation while we do this.
Well, when did you wanna take our trip together?
Oh, yeah.
We're supposed to... Are we going to Japan together?
Or wait... where?
Do you wanna go?
I'm down.
Do you wanna go to...
I wanna do Universal...
No, well, I'll message you a date.
I wanna do like Universal Studios, though.
I feel like I've never been to... I've only been to Universal Studios once.
Oh!
And it was for like...
I think we have to do the clock, right?
Yeah, we have to destroy the clock.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got this one.
Okay, last one.
The floor...
Okay, to be fair, this night in general cost a lot of money for no... for...
Oh, no!
Yeah, it definitely does.
Yeah.
They're like...
They're like so...
I wanna...
Okay, you know what I really want?
I wanna do Universal Japan in Halloween.
Cause like I heard...
Oh!
Halloween...
No, I actually wanted to go in October.
I hear like Halloween Universal Japan is like really, really fun.
Really?
Yeah.
With all the ghosties?
Yeah, cause like...
It's like super creative, like their costumes.
Wait, do I have to help you?
Oh, we have to...
Are you doing this?
Yeah!
Oh, I think...
You...
Um...
You go on the side and then...
And then...
And then we go here and you have to do that.
Where's the other one?
Oh, there it is.
I'm very slowly going down.
Up behind you.
And then...
Where does this go?
I already turned it.
The most I could turn.
Turn it backwards.
Oh, there it is.
There it is to your back.
No, I don't think so.
Is it not?
Cause then...
Bring it.
Oh, no.
Doki!
No!
You win!
How was I supposed to know?
Cause I was supposed to stay on it!
Oh, no.
Okay.
Hello?
Dude, I hate this slow motion jump.
I'm gonna fall soon!
Oh, no.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I do not have much time left.
Oh, there's something in front of you.
I know.
The camera keeps automatically turning.
Oh!
Goodbye, cruel world.
Goodbye.
Where are you now?
Did it go to this one?
I don't know.
Is it this one or this one?
Is that one?
Stop turning my camera!
I'm not doing anything!
I'm not talking to you!
Apparently, you went backwards.
What?
Here?
Okay.
This has to be the right way, yeah?
Oh, there it is.
Why can't we...
I'm so fucking dead.
There's no way I'm gonna live through this.
There's something below you.
This?
Is this everything?
Is this the one?
Oh, no.
Where, though?
Are you really almost there, though?
Like...
What happened?
Why did you do this?
Goodbye.
Goodbye, cruel world.
Where am I?
I don't know.
I'm trying to take you somewhere.
Where are you?
Do I move you or what?
There's one here.
Oh.
Oh, there's one here.
There's one here.
That's not going backwards, is it?
I don't know.
I can't tell anymore.
I feel like it is.
But maybe it's not.
I can't tell anymore.
I can't tell.
This one is the one that goes up.
Are you going backwards?
I can't tell.
Okay.
And then I go back on this bridge.
No, no, no.
This here.
Okay.
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
That thingy!
Oh, there it is!
Yeah!
Okay, wait...
Wait, you're going...
Are you going backwards?
I can't tell.
I think you are.
No!
Oh, you're not.
Okay.
Okay, we're okay, guys.
Everything is fine.
Oh, okay.
Why can't we be friends?
Is that it?
Do I jump on the clock?
I guess so.
Try.
Oh, I can jump on the glass.
Oh, thank God!
Okay, I'm okay now
Oh, I love being Cody
What is going on?
What the fuck are we doing?
Equal distribution of effort Team Cody!
I think I need a nap I think I need a nap after this.
Bro, you slept at 5.
We supposed to We slept at 5 I know, but I was planning on doing a 16 hour stream Oh yeah, because you're doing like TFT and also Minecraft later Hey, hey there girl Maybe I will take a nap after this game We're in sync!
We have chemistry!
What?
Ew!
Oh God!
Truth?
Uh-huh!
Okay, okay!
That's the way you wanna go?
Uh-huh!
Okay!
You like it?
Yeah!
Ew!
Okay!
Let's do it!
Uh-huh!
What happened to our legs at first?
Wait, we're in a clock Why was there like a house in this clock?
Dude, imagine being Rose and your house is slowly falling apart and your parents won't wake the fuck up Like, who's gonna be making dinner?
Mom, it's working!
Our cuckoo clock is working again!
That's nice, sweetie Kazoo, leave me alone!
Mommy had too much fixie juice, so she needs to sleep now What the fuck, Rose?
Get the fuck down from there!
This will make mom happy Yes, a clock She likes sleeping during the wrong time
That's it?
What the fuck?
Oh hey, it's not- it's not her therapy session!
Letter piece number one!
Numero uno!
Dear mom Notice I'm first Are you ready for piece number two?
Yeah, but she blames- she said dear mom and she blames it on herself!
Letter number two!
What else besides love makes couples stay together?
A child Dude, tell her we don't have to go through four of these sieges Attraction!
Oh god!
We need people together!
We don't need attraction!
We're getting divorced!
Aha!
That's because you lost it!
But don't worry, I'll help you find attraction again!
Oh god!
Dude, get this guy off my screen This is abuse This is torture, let me out You can't force someone to like each other again!
Holy shit!
Oh, it's the snow level!
I've seen this level!
I did not think this game was this long!
I told you it was a 14 plus hour game, what do you mean?
Dude, I thought that's because people try to get like every secret or some shit
Attraction is like a magnet, but you need both poles!
No sound!
Plus, minus!
Cody, man!
And the plus...
No, he said plus, minus!
Yeah!
This magnet will help you discover your tracks!
I'm the plus!
One is plus, one is minus!
Oh!
That's not how it works!
Red is minus, blue is plus, who gets blue?
Me!
What?
I got the plus!
Oh!
I'm the plus!
I got...
And when a negative plus a negative comes together, it makes a positive Okay, so we don't have two negatives, we have a positive and a negative The negative comes together Yes!
This is where we had our first skiing trip together!
Oh my god!
That's our first skiing trip!
That's us!
Oh, it's a snow globe!
We're stuck inside that snow globe we bought there!
Get to the top of the mountain to receive your next piece of the letter!
Yeah, what if we freeze to death trying to get there?
Hahaha!
Use your magnet powers and the attraction will warm you up, baby!
Oh god!
Eww!
Is he like humping the snow globe?
He did not need to do that!
I'm gonna break the snow globe the moment we get out It's compromised That was so freaking gross That was pretty gross, yeah Guys, how much do we have left from this game?
Oh, I sure hope so Wait, what?
Really?
Let me try!
Hehe Hehe You're not blue, man!
Why can't you open it anymore?
Oh, it's because of me!
Wait, how do I do this?
I did it!
You're welcome, Malaney!
Oh god!
Hahaha!
We have four more!
Okay, you want LG this level?
Hahaha!
Alright, nice!
I'll go fuck myself, I guess Wait, what?
Do you need me?
Different colors attract, same colors repel!
I can't do anything here!
Oh, I can!
Haha!
I'll leave this one for you!
Alright, nice!
Oh, like usual!
Yay!
What a team!
Wait, is there something we should do?
Oh!
I'm red!
What the?
It launched me!
Wait, what?
Where am I?
Ready?
Different colors attract, same colors repel!
What are you doing?
What the hell?
Why are you swimming?
It launched me off?
And then it like...
Wait...
What?
Okay...
Alright, and then I push this?
Can I not push this?
What am I supposed to do?
Let me... let me...
Oh, you do it!
But it was red!
Okay, you do it.
Cause...
Oh!
Yeah, but I'm red!
And now I do this.
Don't leave me here, Koji!
Help me get over!
Let me go!
I'm doing it!
Teamwork!
Oh, cause it's blue!
And I'm red!
And with magnets!
You're opposite to Tron!
Hahaha!
I just learned how to use magnets!
I just learned how to use magnets, guys!
I'm red!
See, every day I learn something new!
Every day!
Hey!
Remember our first Christmas with Rose?
You mean when all the Christmas trees were sold out?
Yeah!
And we snuck into the woods and cut down one ourselves?
Guys, how do they work?
When you have two of the same color...
You push them away!
But when you have like...
Opposite colors...
You pull them in!
You should have taught me this instead of me figuring it out.
So, opposites attract...
But if you have two of the same kind, you repel each other.
Yeah!
Oh!
So it'll push me up.
Cause opposite...
Same thing, people!
Push each other away!
Okay.
It's me cause I'm red.
And what do you do?
I need you to pull that to... I need you to pull that, innit?
I feel like you have to pull it.
I can't pull it.
Yeah, I don't reach it.
Oh, wait.
There's something else here.
Oh, there's something else here.
You're supposed to pull that.
Phew!
I think you have to pull it all the way.
I'm pretty sure.
Well, stop!
There we go.
And then...
And then I pull this.
See?
I pull this.
And then you go in.
And then I launch you.
Oh...
And then you do that.
Yeah, and then I can pull it now.
Yeah, oh I can't, I can't!
You gotta push it more!
Just barely got on my hands.
I got it.
Yay!
I'm coming over my love.
That's fucked up.
That's fucked up, man.
I gave you my love.
And the very next day, you gave it up.
You pushed me away.
Don't leave me.
You can't run away from this handsome hunk of a man forever.
I'm gonna die.
I
am a catch, okay?
I am a 10 out of 10.
Dude, any guy who tells you that...
I'm a catch!
I'm a 10 out of 10!
Now I'm different!
Okay, that's awesome.
There, here, I gave it to you.
I literally gave you the thing.
Why are you pulling that way?
Because you need to get the blue.
To get closer.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, you need to get the...
Blue repels.
No.
Yeah!
I learned magnets.
I know how magnet works.
Yay!
Oh, your thingy.
Lo...
Your thingy.
Go for it.
Why did you do that?
I'm helping!
Go!
Wait, why did you get back?
How did you get back there?
Because I...
I was trying to launch off of it!
Alright, go, go.
Go for your blue.
There you go.
See?
Chat, am I a 10 out of 10?
Any wife would be happy to have me.
Right?
Anybody would want me as a husband.
See?
Look at all the people that said yes.
And look at all the people I ignored that said something else.
That said something else.
Clearly, the other thing did not matter.
Damn, 100% people thought I am a cat.
Fast travel.
What's this?
I'm helping.
Wait, how do we...
We have to do...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Oh, where am I?
You have to go to that... you see that other blue thing?
You have to go there.
There's a blue thing over there.
Wait, where are you?
Where did I go?
You went backwards.
You literally went back.
I know!
I got launched!
Wait, if you die, maybe it'll respawn next to me.
You think so?
Yeah.
Oh, my leg.
Oh.
Yeah, see?
You're next to it.
Yo!
Wait...
No.
Go!
You have to.
There's a blue thing over there on the other side.
What do you mean, no?
No.
What do you mean?
Off.
Get off.
I did.
No.
What do you mean?
That's how you do it.
Wait...
Do I...
The blue thing repels, no?
I repel it!
No, you have to...
You get on and then you get to that blue.
Is that blue over there?
Yeah, and then I repel the blue because I repel it.
Wait, huh?
Then how do we do this?
Then you do it.
Yeah, you do it.
How do you do it?
Do I have to pull this over here?
I guess so.
Oh!
Oh, what if I like bring it to you and then you...
Push it a little.
Yeah, I bring it to you and then you do...
Oh, my God.
We're so smart.
Why?
We know magnets.
Why did you keep telling me to go get pulled by blue when you know...
Why are you jumping?
I didn't know what that was.
I thought it was a box.
Oh, God.
I gotta go to sleep.
I think you're right.
We're rekindling our love.
Oh, my God.
Do I have anything in my pants?
What?
We're rekindling our love.
You know what we'll fix our marriage?
Another kid.
Maybe we just... we just...
We just have two little kids.
I feel like that's actually how some married couples think.
Dude, I feel like that's actually how some married couples think.
Dude, I'm done.
I'm fucking... I hate it here.
Another child will fix this.
We just need another baby in the house.
Was it this cozy when we were here?
I miss when your boobies were bigger...
...because we had a baby.garbling Can I be out of here for a while?
Dude, I read a post like that recently and I was like, Am I the asshole... for wanting my wife to be pregnant... because her boobs are bigger?
Oh!
That's real?
I'm pretty sure it's a meet up pose.
Yeah, no man would fucking write that.
Oh my god.
Bro.
There's no way a guy actually wrote that.
That's so...
There's a guy who...
It has to be a joke.
It was a real life story.
But the guy was like, My name is Jarvan, and boy do I love breast milk.
No, but that's a thing.
That's a real fetish.
Yeah, but like...
Then people probably...
Some men do feel that way.
Yeah.
You understand.
What?
Some people are ass men, and some people are boobs.
Some people like butts, and some like boobs.
I understand.
Are we going in the right way?
Okay.
Pull the fucking door, man.
Yeah, sorry.
Mommy?
Sorry.
So I was like, did you read my bio?
Yeah, I get it.
Pussy in bio.
Some people like...
Some people are the front, some people are the backs.
And sometimes both.
Where are they?
This town used to be like your relationship.
Alive and fun!
But look at it now.
Silent.
Dead.
Frozen.
You need to wake it up from its winter sleep!
How are we gonna do that?
You like it smaller up top.
So I was like, Please do not conflate breast appreciators with milk enthusiasts.
The two are completely different schools of thought.
What?
What did they say?
They're like, Please don't group us together with those who like milk.
Please don't group us together with those who like milk.
Oh my god.
Bro.
And some people like that.
The ancient ninja rivalry.
Wait, is it me?
I don't know.
Am I supposed to push it?
Oh, I think you pull it.
Yeah, it's me.
Then you have to press this button.
Wait, what?
This opens something.
Right?
It lifts this rock up.
But like, what does that do?
Confused.
What are you supposed to do here?
Oh!
Wait.
Am I supposed to watch him?
Oh, can I pull it even further?
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
I can pull it?
Oh, I can pull it further!
Oh!
Why do you keep doing this?
Why?
Oh!
I'm learning.
Oh, it goes nothing.
More and more I learn every day.
Oh!
I learn more and more every day.
Why do you keep doing this?
What do you mean?
Oh my god, they're alive!
Killed it.
Yay!
Oh my god, they're like the Ice King from Adventure Time.
They're like mini Ice Kings.
It reminded me of the guys from...
The island from Mario Sunshine.
Oh yeah!
But with clothes on!
We did good.
We did this.
Oh my god, they're alive!
It looks like how I remember it now.
You remember it like this, you freak?
That's you.
Oh my god, look at her back!
You're calling yourself a freak.
Oh, that's so cute!
Why are you calling yourself a freak?
Hey!
We gotta open the door.
We gotta open the door!
I'm on my own.
Oh!
That's so pretty.
Can you host another poll?
Why?
What's the poll?
What was the poll you did last time?
The reason for the divorce.
No, no.
The other poll was like, am I a 10 out of 10 catch?
You know, I would...
Yeah, I'm gonna write that.
Am I...
Hustle and bustle when we were here.
Am I a 10 out of 10...
Oh shit, I'm big again.
Catch of a husband.
Am I a 10 out of 10...
There we go.
That's my poll.
I gotta fix myself because I'm big again.
And I accidentally went big.
Give me a sec.
No, I'm big.
What the fuck?
What did I do?
Oh my god, what did I do?
Okay.
There we go.
Big.
Not big anymore.
Hold on, I need to vote real quick.
Wait, what do you mean?
Why do you need a vote?
Cause we're the one that's...
I'm literally married to you.
What?
Why do you need a vote?
I don't understand.
Look, see?
More people think I'm a catch!
And then the others' opinions don't matter.
So it's 100% right!
It's 100%!
I knew it.
I think this is how men's egos inflate.
What do you mean?
I just saw it in real time.
What the fuck do you mean?
I'm a 10 out of 10!
What?
You're the worst husband I've ever been married to.
I'm the worst?
You had multiple husbands?
I thought you had multiple wives, not husbands.
Hey man.
Damn!
Have you seen 707 from Mystic Messenger?
You know what?
This is exactly why I'm getting a divorce.
I'm gonna find somebody that's gonna appreciate me as a husband.
What do I do here?
I don't know.
What am I throwing?
This?
Oh, I'm giving you magnets!
Take it.
Did you fall?
What are you doing?
You see, my new wife is gonna figure this out faster.
I'm not doing puzzles for us anymore.
What are you doing?
It's fucked up.
What the fuck?
You do puzzles by yourself now.
What are you doing?
Go fucking get the magnet!
You can leave when we're people again.
I'm coming!
I don't wanna fall!
There ya go.
You're welcome.
You're lucky.
You're lucky I don't hold grudges.
I'm getting like actual war flashbacks.
Fun dad!
Fun dad's here!
Oh god.
I think I did all my stuff.
Fun dad!
Oh god.
I just had a PTSD moment.
What hours?
I think I need to cut my hair.
Hours!
Where do we go from here?
That was...
Woah!
It's so beautiful!
Let's go to the other tower.
Did you cut your hair?
Are you pulling a Mulan?
Kubi?
Kubi, you okay?
Guys, I don't know what's gonna happen.
Was it me?
No, it can't be me.
I can never be the issue.
Kubi!
Kubi, I need help!
Kubi, I'm on the other side!
Where are you, Kubi?
Get on the owl!
I just cut off three locks of my hair.
Oh no!
What happened?
I'm gonna get you!
We're over.
Did you...
Did you overdose on the fun?
Did you just have too much fun?
I understand.
I don't think...
Get on the owl and go to the other side.
I'm on the other side of the tower.
Like really other side.
Oh, hey Snowball.
Oh, I'm gonna get ya!
I think you're back to being wife number four.
What?
I was always wife number four!
What about husband?
You got promoted to wife number two.
Do you know what?
Now you're wife number five.
What?
I think I need to get a new one.
What did I do?
Say that again.
Say it again.
Bullseye!
Gonna be back in my wife spot right now.
Okay, for both of this we need...
We need to do the puzzle!
Do the puzzle!
You can't hold on to that Snowball forever.
Alright, I can grab more.
Come on!
Oh my god, do the puzzle!
I got homing missiles.
This is fucked up.
Then, what do I have to do?
Watch out, man.
Oh, here.
I couldn't tell where the walls were.
What do you mean?
Okay, here we go.
I can hold on to this for just a little bit.
I don't think you have to pull.
Let go.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, now let go.
Wait, what?
Wait.
What?
Stay?
Yeah.
Oh, you don't let go.
Oh, whoops.
Did you do that again?
Fun Dad, Fun Dad.
Yay!
Fun Dad's here.
Fun Dad, Fun Dad.
Yay!
I'm so fun.
Oh!
What did you...
I have to do that again.
Don't worry.
That means more time for Fun Dad.
Come on.
Get me out of here.
More time to spend for Fun Dad.
Yay!
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Yay!
Longer time for Fun Dad.
Woo!
Okay, I'm ready.
You have to take me to the other side again.
Nice.
I'm here.
Yeah!
Oh god.
We did it!
Pancakes!
Oh my god, there's food!
Can I borrow like five dollars?
No!
You're right.
We share a bank account.
I already cut you off.
It's okay.
We share a bank account.
I moved all the funds back to my personal bank account.
Wait, that's so fucked up.
You can't do that legally.
We're getting divorced.
We can.
We're not divorced yet.
I don't trust you with fun.
What do you mean you don't trust my fun?
I'm so fun.
We have to head to the other tower.
I'm at the other tower?
Hiya!
We gotta free these guys.
Free these nuts.
Oh wait.
Get over here.
Fun Dad's waiting for the fun.
Bad move.
Yeah, if you do that, my lawyer has a case for me.
We signed a prenup.
No, I did.
I forgot to sign it.
You have to go to the other...
Oh wait, no.
I have to.
Wait, no.
You have to because of tracks.
No.
Alright.
What do you have to do now?
You need to turn it.
I turn, I turn, I turn.
Wait, wait, wait.
Keep turning.
I turn.
Here I am.
I'm here now.
Yay!
I did it!
I'm up.
And then...
Okay.
Oh my god, we're so smart.
This is why we're perfect for each other.
Do you have to pull this?
What does it opposite to tracked mean?
Yeah, so you pull it down.
Get on the freaking thing!
I didn't know that was an elevator.
I didn't know it was an elevator!
Get on the freaking thing.
I'm sorry.
Context clues!
Where are my explicit context clues?
Oh, there's a Ferris wheel!
There's a gondola lift?
Oh, it's over there!
We go to the gondola!
Wow, this guy is huge.
Woah!
Wait, I can like make this go fast.
That's looking right.
Have fun!
Dude, I love those rides!
Fun time!
I love those rides at a carnival.
Fun forever!
That's right, you're all gonna have fun forever!
What the hell?
I'm going to the gondola.
How do you get to the gondola?
Opposite a track.
Wait, it won't let me get on.
How do I... Oh, there it is!
Are you okay?
Yeah, that was me stretching.
I'm heading... I'm getting there.
Don't worry, the gondola is working.
It's a Ferris wheel, man.
No, it's a gondola!
See?
And then...
Why didn't you want to go on the Ferris wheel with me?
And then we go down there.
Because you tried to...
Beat my ass with snowballs.
You started it!
What?
Hey!
An aquarium!
What?
Yeah, that's right, I said it.
How do we turn this...
How did you get in?
Oh, there's how you get in there.
I'm pushing!
Why aren't you pushing?
Is it fun, Dad?
Dude, the thing is my character won't move.
Wait, why are you stuck?
Just kidding.
I'm moving now.
Yeah!
Look, this is a gondola, okay?
Those are... oh, so that's a mini gondola.
It's a mini gondola.
Yeah!
Why didn't you want to do the Ferris wheel with me?
It's romantic.
Get away from me!
What do you mean, we're husband and wife?
I wanted a boyfriend.
Get away from me!
Give daddy a kiss!
No!
Just no!
You still like it!
What happened?
You still like this!
I don't want a kiss!
Run, come here!
We can fix this marriage if we just give each other a little kiss!
I don't want a kiss!
A little kiss!
But it's a party!
Come on!
We can get a bar!
Oh, shit!
Oh, look, this hat!
I'm taking his hat.
Oh, look at me!
I have this hat!
This one fits perfectly!
Nice hat!
I have it.
Look at my hat!
I'm not compensating for anything.
I just think it's a really nice hat.
It's time for another child to fix our marriage.
I don't...
Why is this guy...
Oh my god, look at this guy.
Why is he T -posing?
Look at him.
Oh, look at...
Oh, we're gonna be bobsledding!
Hey, Cody!
Nice hat!
Oh, yeah!
Hey, nice hat!
It's bobsled time!
That's right, I'm a better button masher.
Oh!
Can we review the second game?
Look at me go!
Yeah!
I'm winning!
Dad's winning!
Because I know how to have fun.
Look at me go.
I take a nappy.
Oh, no!
I missed it!
It's a ride!
Okay, nice.
We're going.
I have racing games experience.
Where are we?
We're like in a tunnel.
It's a tunnel.
Oh my god, is that fish?
Oh, we're in a fish now.
We're in a fucking fish now.
Eww!
Did you see the blood in that one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That is...
Oh, I am!
I'm moving dick!
Oh, why is it so bloody?
Hi!
Is he dead?
Stop crashing into me, man!
Or is he alive?
Oh, he's definitely dead.
Why do you mean is it alive?
That's a hole.
Did you see the outside?
I don't know, maybe he's sleeping.
He could be sleeping.
You know that.
Hibernation.
Why does he have a hole?
That's so weird.
I'm ahead of my screen, but...
Yeah, I'm gonna see.
Earlier, I was ahead...
What?
No, I'm still ahead.
I was so scared.
He's just hibernating like bears.
Did you know bears don't actually hibernate?
That's what's just...
Yeah, I know.
You knew?
We made that shit up to tell kids.
I blame Spongebob.
I don't believe it.
I learned that yesterday.
Bears don't hibernate.
We did a poll and they voted on who's more dependent on the other.
You won.
Congratulations.
Wait, on your poll?
Uh-huh.
It just means I won't make this marriage to work.
It means I put more effort in trying to fix this marriage.
No, it means you're more dependent on my pun.
It means I'm trying.
He has killed many a surface.
I did.
And I did.
I'm trying to fix him.
On the day that I uh- No, not water level...
Water level?
That looks chilly.
I don't do well in cold water.
No, not water level.
Should we put the water level for next time?
I don't wanna do water level.
We have to finish the chapter out.
No.
Not the water level.
Where do I go?
I'm already lost.
I have to go to you.
I'm here.
I thought everyone loves water levels.
No, water levels are...
It's the music that's good, but the gameplay fucking sucks.
Except the Pokemon games.
That's not really a water level though.
I don't know.
Dude, I kind of miss those old Pokemon games where you could deep dive into the sea.
Oh yeah, I know what you're talking about.
The one where you go to the ruins and stuff.
Yay!
Oh, he's angry.
Dude, imagine being this wack ass book where you created these characters and you pretend to talk to them.
He's just like me in fourth grade.
He's writing his own story.
He has no one else to talk to, so he makes up imaginary friends.
Yeah, just like me in fourth grade.
Did you also hump snow globes too, like him?
No.
But I will!
I'll say... nope, nevermind, I don't want to say it.
Okay.
You hear that?
Without sweetness, a relationship will die.
Oh, you say something?
I was opening a rice cracker.
Meenie is senbei.
I don't make some appreciation for working overtime to support the family.
Right now.
Well, there was that time when...
Meenie, thanks for working overtime.
I did it.
Turn on the candy production and make the sweetness blow again!
Hope you packed your toolkit.
What the hell?
Damn, why am I so bitter?
No!
Water the book!
Fuck!
Ehhhhhhhhh!
Oh, there's some fishies!
There's a leak here!
We need to fix it somehow!
How do we fix it?
Help me with this wrench, Cody!
Here?
Wait, what?
It's turning, it's turning!
That's a big fish!
What do we do?
I refuse to be fixed!
AHHH!
FISH!
I was not a fan of that!
Wait, what do we do?
Ohhhhhhh!
Help me!
Help me, Cody!
Where are you?
Wait, where are you?
Oh, there you are!
Okay, I get it.
AHHHHH!
He's coming!
Oh, I'm stuck!
I'm stuck!
Where am I?
Oh, I got it!
I got it!
I think I just lost a few years there!
I'm helping!
Where do we pull it to?
Where are we pulling it to?
Here?
To the... to the... that thing!
That thing!
I'm pulling it to you!
Where are you pulling it to?
My beautiful wife!
See?
I did my job!
And then we... where do we push it to?
Righty tighty!
Turn it!
I'm turning it!
Are we doing the wrong one?
I'm scared.
Is he coming?
I don't think so.
Maybe it's the other way.
Is it the other way?
Yeah, it was... You pulled the wrong way!
Righty tighty!
Alright, nice.
I'm going to go to the other one.
I got it.
It can't eat all of us!
Why did you let go?
What do you mean, why did I let go?
Pull it!
Please!
I'm so weak!
You didn't marry me for my beautiful body!
Or maybe you did.
You just...
Once again, arranged marriage.
My parents lost to that.
Yes, but then the more you spent time with me, the more you fell in love with me.
It's like Beauty and the Beast.
I'm Beauty.
Beauty and the Beast.
We can make it make complete.
Let's see.
We did it!
Yay!
One more.
Where did he go?
Where's the last one?
Ow!
I'm dead.
By the way, I'm alive.
Wait, where do we... where's the last one?
But the last one's behind.
I see it.
I'm beast.
I see where it is.
I'm heading over.
It's this way behind us.
Oh my gosh.
I know.
I'm just waiting.
I'm heading over.
I'm going to go over there.
To make my life complete.
Oh shit!
It's okay.
It didn't get me.
Dodged.
Yeah.
Gotta go up.
Bring it up.
It's stuck under here.
All right.
Nice.
Twisty turny.
Oh my...
We fixed it.
Hey, it's working.
I fixed it.
That's yummy.
Mom.
Let's find another one.
I'm going to do one more.
Two more?
Wait.
How do we get out of here?
Okay.
Let's go.
Wait.
How do we get out of here?
That's the machine.
Oh, it's backwards.
It's backwards.
Went the wrong way.
Oh.
That's right.
That's why you have me.
I know where I'm going.
Somehow you give me the ick more and more.
Each line you say.
What do you mean?
Every line you say gives me the ick.
What?
I have tried so hard to help us.
You know...
I am trying my hardest.
Yeah, maybe you should stop trying.
I am trying my hardest right now, but you don't appreciate me.
Maybe it's time to give it a break.
Where do we go?
Here?
But we did this, didn't we?
Maybe this way?
Oh, it's this way.
I figured it out.
It's here.
It's a swordfish.
I wait.
Oh, the fuck?
Whoa!
Swim up and down.
We need to?
Oh, we have to.
We have to make sure we don't die to that.
Okay.
Oh!
It's like only one of us makes it through.
That's all that matters, right?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Wait, no.
I meant like me.
What?
Yeah, you make it through.
No, no.
I meant like I have the privilege to die.
Okay, your turn.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, here we go.
I'm coming over.
Doki does have negative Riz.
I don't know how.
How do I have negative Riz?
63% of the majority of people voted that like I'm 10 out of 10.
Like I don't understand.
How do we get out of here?
I'm like stuck in the water.
Yeah, I think up there.
What?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
At least I don't feel cold because I'm a doll.
Yay!
I pressed the wrong button.
Okay, here we go.
What the fuck?
Why do I keep pressing the wrong button?
Do you need me over there?
Okay, nice.
Nice.
I made it!
Weeeeee!
What the hell?
It's okay.
I'll show you how it's done.
Yay!
Okay, you pressed the wrong button again.
No, it's okay.
I learned how to do it.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, that's so cool.
Ow.
Don't worry.
I'll grab the checkpoint so you can just spawn next to me.
Oh, thank you.
Don't worry.
Your boo's got it.
Did you just call me?
Or call yourself my boo?
That's some mouse.
What do you mean?
We're married.
That's some mouse.
That is called a dokey riz.
She liked it, guys.
I think she liked it.
I felt like that was equivalent to some random guy at the bar saying, hey, what's up, shawty?
She liked it, guys.
What do we do here?
Oh, you have to push and then I push and then you push.
Let's go.
What are you doing, Chris?
We are.
Yeah, you miss all the shots you don't shoot.
Exactly!
Hey, but sometimes you should shoot your shot.
Sometimes.
Like, you have to keep going until it hits.
Are we supposed to jump up there?
Up here.
Wheeeee!
How do we get back, though?
Oh.
Oh, you didn't tell me press X, you can go faster.
Wheeeee!
They tell you that at the very beginning.
Ice race, let's go!
Okay, green pass through the... complete a lap.
I got this.
Chat, watch this.
But like, if I don't got this, don't watch.
Here comes the ice race!
Oh no.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
What the fuck?
You can find.
That's okay.
Woo!
That's exactly right.
Yeah!
I'm so fucking fast!
That's crazy.
I didn't know you can take the rings in front of me.
Hahaha!
Oh, chirpies!
If you were for me, you would take it.
It's like the Mario Kart item.
Chirpies so slow!
I was freaking.
If you were a little faster, then you could have taken these rings.
Yeah, and that's why I'm divorcing you, because you go a little too fast.
Wooohooo!
What the fuck in front of everybody?
Hahaha!
They had to know the truth.
I thought, I thought we were keeping a private.
I thought we were keeping a private.
Hahaha!
What the fuck?
Some people like that.
You know that.
Yeah!
Honestly?
My new wife would love it.
I'm already planning.
Hahaha!
What the fuck?
Yes!
Hahaha!
I think you're right.
You're a sore loser.
Yeah, I'm just gonna say it.
Wait, how did you win?
What?
I won.
Wait, what?
How did you?
I followed the path properly.
What?
How?
I think I got more rings than you.
How did you win?
I got more rings than you.
I'm missing checklist.
I apparently missing checkpoint.
I'm missing.
Wha...
What?
I didn't even realize.
I can't...
I went too fast.
I went...
that's what I was saying.
I can't believe you can actually go too fast.
That's so fucked up.
I can't believe it.
Everything's a lie.
Come on, come.
Why?
Everything's a fucking lie!
One day you'll learn your lesson.
Today might not be that day.
I'm so sad.
I need to fucking head to bed and listen to some Linkin Park.
Where do we go?
Here?
Oh, it's back here.
Where's the last one though?
Which one did we do already?
I can't tell.
Everything looks the same.
Which one are we missing?
This one.
Oh, it's this one.
We follow this pipe.
I see it.
I feel so empty inside.
Okay!
I feel so empty.
I don't have the Seabat rhythm!
What do you mean?
That's a good rhythm anyway.
You guys are just fucking...
Where the fuck are you?
I don't know.
How did you get there?
How do you get in there?
What the fuck?
I'm so confused.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
I figured it out.
What do you do?
Here, stay right there.
Okay.
I stay here?
Go pull the other side.
There's another side?
Oh, there is!
Wait, there's no other side.
What are you talking about?
I think I have to find the hole.
I have experience with that.
Don't worry.
Watch this.
Wait.
Give me a sec.
Oh, it's here!
It's here!
Wait, no.
Wait.
Wait, Gumi.
I need help.
What do I do, Gumi?
I need you to teach me.
What do I do?
I felt like you saw it.
I didn't.
What do I do?
Go find the hole.
But what if I can't find it?
Where?
Where is the hole?
Is it here?
No.
No, that's not...
Where is it?
This is... This is the hole.
Hole?
Or maybe it's here.
No.
The hole is the goal.
Are you divorced yet?
I wish.
I'm here, but this is not open.
Hey!
I think I need you to open this one for me.
Yeah, you need to open this.
Yeah, see?
I knew it wasn't me!
I can see the generator!
It's on the opposite side!
To be fair, I saw it earlier, but I wanted to see if you would say something.
I knew it!
I knew it wasn't me!
It's a group effort.
It's pretty warm in here.
Is that lava?
Where do we have to take me to?
Here?
I don't think so, right?
Is it here?
Ah, halfway there.
So where do we go from here?
Yeah, we're...
I don't think it's this way.
I think we have to go above.
Do you turn more or no?
Where do we go from here?
Woo!
Hey!
Try turning it around!
Oh, yeah, yeah!
There we go!
And then you turn... I have to go higher.
Can I go higher or no?
Go higher.
I'm trying!
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice!
That's high enough!
Yay!
I know it's a bit difficult to rely on you right now.
I think I need to go to sleep.
I'm doing it!
Yeah!
I did it!
Yay!
Why do I feel like Mei does a lot of the heavy lifting?
Oh no.
I feel like I did an equal amount of work there.
There's no I in marriage.
Oh my God.
There's an I in marriage!
Did you notice that?
I'm saying that this entire time.
I just blocked you out.
You say some shit like, oh teamwork, look teamwork, and I just block it out.
A marriage needs communication, Gumi.
You need to communicate when you feel like it's too much.
I communicate to you, but you need to start listening to me.
Huh?
You say something?
Push.
I think I need to go make another artichoke.
Oh no!
What about your artichoke?
What?
I need to make it for grandpa!
Is she left to make her artichoke?
I think she left to make her artichoke.
This is gonna be so romantic.
Oh no, Gumi's not gonna be here to see the romance blossom between us.
Yeah, for grandpa.
Yeah, we have earned it.
See, we!
Even the game agrees this is teamwork.
I don't understand.
You know, we haven't been on vacation since Rose was born.
Really?
Has it been that long?
Yep.
Why did we stop going skiing?
Well, Rose was born...
Cause Rose hates skiing!
...and the bills piled up.
Yeah.
Yeah, I guess.
She hates the snow.
...and the link in the roof, remember?
Oh, don't remind me.
Maybe once we sold the house, there might be some money left over for a weekend trip.
See?
Timer for f**king f**king it!
And you could take Rose to Waterland.
Yeah, it's a great idea.
She's been bugging us all summer to take her there.
And then I'll take her again when it's my turn.
Yeah, she'll have to go twice!
Oh my god, we're talking about custody!
Yeah, double the fun.
Can you say something?
We're talking about the custody!
You're gonna have full custody, right?
Let's race!
What?
I thought you were the fun-shot- fun dad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, but I come over like once every- once a week.
So like, she'll continue with things.
Thinking I'm fun.
Because I only show up when it's fun time.
Come on, be elite, Cody!
Yeah, you're the best kid, boo!
So it's like, you know, I can be like, Rose, it's time to go to the amusement park!
It's daddy's time!
The Sunday dad!
Yeah, I'm the Sunday dad!
Exactly!
Best kind!
So she'll always remember me as the fun one.
Woo!
It's sundad!
Yeah!
Instead of Sunday, it's sundad!
I figured it out.
Lame!
What do you mean lame?
You're just jealous because you're not the fun mom.
Yeah, and then I'm gonna have a badass motorcycle.
And- I'm gonna have my midlife crisis.
And then Rose is gonna be like, um, um, Mom!
Why aren't you as fun as sundad?
I'm going to dad's!
And then she's gonna see me in my, um, in my bachelor pad.
And it's gonna look so fucking sad.
And I'll be like, Rose, what are you doing here?
Hey!
I'm seeing you make it!
It's not sundad day!
And she's gonna be like, yeah, mom was wishing me, can I live off your money and bills now?
And then I was like, oh, sweetie.
We have an arrangement.
There's a reason why I'm sundad.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
This guy, this guy looks scary.
Bro, he's chained up.
I have a feeling we should- Yeah, me too.
He's chained up for a reason.
Why are you going this way?
There's no way to- I thought we can wall jump this, but there's no way to do that.
Oh, take him near- oh, wait, wait, take him over here!
Yeah, let me bring him.
Oh, is that a monster?
That's too real.
Whatever it is, I'm glad it's frozen.
But I'm fun.
At least I'll be fun.
I'm stuck.
I don't know how to put you out.
You don't pull, you push, remember?
You push!
You push, remember?
Push.
Stop pushing.
Oh.
Yay.
Magnets!
Yeah!
I love magnets.
Help me, Stepdokie.
Oh my god, no, and then you're gonna get- You're gonna- I'll be like the cool dad, and then I fucked up.
Why did you-
I think you're supposed to- no, it's because you're supposed to take me to the fishhooks over there.
I didn't fuck up, I realized we fucked up together.
Because I was supposed to go to the fishhooks.
Yeah, and then when your mom remarries, when Gumi remarries, you're gonna realize your stepdad is not as cool as me.
I'm gonna show up with my badass motorcycle, and I'll be like, oh, is- is- is Jerry treating you okay, Rose?
What's with you?
You're gonna name Jerry, man.
I bet Jerry didn't bring you a pony.
Alright, what is this?
Oh wait, no?
What do I do here?
Alright, pull this down?
What is this?
Many times do I have to teach you, old man, you're not pulling nothing.
I'm a little confused.
How do you get here?
Did I- Did I fuck something up?
No, I couldn't.
I'm smart.
No, you're supposed to come here!
I- I did a platform for you.
I made you this.
Look, I did this.
I did this.
You're welcome.
Shut up.
Yay!
Alright, and then you're supposed to do this one.
Right here.
No, right here.
Go next to me.
I thought you were- Yeah.
And then I jump over, and you pull it.
Yeah!
We're doing it!
I'm using my brain!
I need a water break.
I'm using 1% of my brain!
This is it!
Boomy?
Boomy.
My hand hurty.
Boomy?
Huh?
The hook?
No, the other one.
Just one to your right.
I don't think this is gonna move.
Yeah, this doesn't move.
It's okay.
I know you don't mean that.
I'm getting ready.
Oh, hahaha!
Alright, nice.
Alright, move me to the other side.
Yay!
Please!
Move me to the other side.
I don't need to say please, we're already married.
Ha ha ha.
Okay.
Haha.
Julmy, I know you want this game to be over, so you have to move me to the other side, okay?
To the other side.
The longer you stay here, the longer we're gonna be playing this game.
You know you can't avoid that.
There you go, I made it.
Nice.
Yay!
The longer you delay this, the longer we stay married.
Okay, here you go.
Woo!
Oh my god, is that bones?
Whose bones are these?
In the f- Yeah, I know, in the cube!
In the snow globe!
Yay!
Woo!
I still can't believe I missed the checkpoint.
I still can't believe.
What'd you say?
I can't believe I missed the checkpoint in that race.
I can't believe it.
I got a little more checkpoints needed.
I thought it was all about going fast and being efficient.
It was all a lie.
I can't wait to eat another artichoke tonight.
I'm still ahead.
Woo!
No you're not.
Wait, what the f- how did you get the airtime?
Where did you get the airtime for this?
Uh-huh.
It's okay, I made it ahead.
Okay.
We're still not at the top?
Oh god.
Ugh.
This man.
Oh god.
Ha!
What the hell?
You mean relationship with a P?
No.
Relation shit.
As in shit like caca.
You need to rebuild your relationship into a relation shit.
Why can't we just close the door on him?
This guy just really likes saying shit, doesn't he?
I wish we could build a fire.
Remember?
When something collapses, something new can be built.
Shark.
And then the attraction can grow freely.
Please.
Please stop.
You know?
Oh no.
This is a PG question for Elyse Shreen.
Let's break it, baby!
Come on!
I'm gonna shark.
Please stop.
I hope you shark your pants.
Stop!
Shark yourself.
We are...
We are mature adults here.
We are mature people.
We do...
We do very smart adult jokes here.
Shark thyself.
So much for a pleasant trip.
What the fuck?
Are you like dashing in front of me?
I'm trying to go as fast as I can.
And I was just having fun.
Woo!
Look at that.
You're having fun almost dying.
That's fucked up.
Eh.
Great.
I'm here.
You know what I'm saying?
You're like extreme sports.
You know Tony Hawk is like almost...
Wait.
He's like 60, right?
That's actually crazy.
He's like somewhere in 50s or 60s now.
And he's still skateboarding.
That's gotta be me when I'm in my 60s.
That's a lie.
Dude, leave us alone.
Leave us alone.
This is creepy.
We can fix our relationship without you.
Oh, God.
We're getting magnetized.
This is the best thing that's ever been done to me.
This is the best thing that I've ever done.
He's still shredding it at 55.
What the fuck are you doing?
How do I do this?
Oh!
You're free now.
We can like body slam.
These babies are strong.
Indeed.
Indeed, the hole is greater than the parts.
The magnet's attraction is getting stronger.
Wait, what the fuck?
It's artichoke time!
Wait, what?
What?
What the fuck?
Be a bat.
Goalie!
What the fuck?
We're still in this game!
At least head over... oh my god.
We're so close to finishing this chapter!
Oh my god!
We were so close!
We were almost there!
Oh...
Artichoke over...
Artichoke...
Let me go!
Why did you pick artichoke?
We were so close.
We were so close to finishing this chapter.
It was literally right there.
Oh my god.
It's okay guys.
One day we can finish this chapter.
One day.
I put... I believe in us.
I can't believe she picked an artichoke over me!
I don't understand!
Can I get a ride?
I can't believe it!
But I'm... I'm Doki!
Look at me!
Look at this...
And I fucking love artichokes.
I can't believe it.
Alright, if I was dangling off a cliff...
but there's an artichoke next to you...
Huh?
Get over here.
Whoops.
Sorry, I went the wrong way.
You... you... you jump to me.
You will attract over... Yeah there he is.
Oh, I can really feel this magnet pulling towards you!
Really?
What does the archer have that I don't have?
Flavor.
What?
What is that?
Good flavor.
Vegetable.
I love vegetable.
I'm not gonna comment anymore.
Oh, wait, what?
Wait, but like, how do...
I'm so confused.
You have to wait until we're both ready.
What do both do at the same time?
I literally just said that.
The artichoke said that.
Okay, go!
Yeah!
We did it!
I love artichoke.
You love it so much, why don't you marry it?
What the fuck are you doing?
I don't know, let's move on.
Whoa.
Oh, I...
What?
Oh, you have to grab onto the side and then I grab onto you.
Oh!
I'm grabbing onto you!
I'm like on your fucking shoulder.
Don't worry, I can grab onto this one.
I'm gonna grab onto this one.
Follow me!
It'd be so funny if I let go right now.
Oh man, I really wanna eat my artichoke.
It'd be so funny.
Alright.
We gotta go to the...
Oh, I think we can make it to the next blue.
I think we can make it.
We can't make it.
Gotta go to the red.
I got it.
Don't worry, I got you.
What are you being tough?
I'm making sure you don't fall.
Incoming gusts!
The storm!
No, get this one!
Yes!
I got you!
I'm holding onto you!
I'm making sure your boots are digging into the snow right now.
Shut up!
What are you doing?
I can't hold the crown!
Alright, we're good.
The wind doesn't reach us here.
There's a cover on the other side, mate!
What are you doing?
The wind!
What the fuck?
Does it not stop?
Oh, I don't think it stops!
I think we have to go to the right!
There's a cover on the other side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have to go.
I just hold onto you.
Yeah.
And then we do this.
Alright.
I think we go here?
Yeah.
Get the fuck off!
The longer we're here, the longer we play this game!
Listen.
That's fine by me.
Then I'll go backwards.
I will go all the way down this mountain.
You think I won't?
You think I will go all the way down this mountain?
Cause I will.
I am that spiteful.
I'm also that spiteful.
Good night.
Well...
I'm swept away!
Oh no!
Just one last push!
This is wrong!
Where are you?
Where the fuck did you go?
Now!
Hey!
I'm losing!
That's looking right.
I didn't need you.
I'm already at the next stage!
Good, I wasn't going to work.
What the fuck?
Where even are you?
I'll wait.
Get over here!
Grip onto me!
Huh?
Oh my god.
How the fuck do I get to the other side?
Get over here!
Say something.
I'm losing grip!
Help!
I don't need you.
Yeah, you do it on your own.
Okay, get over here.
Okay, okay.
I need you.
Get up.
I'm literally right next to you.
You fucker.
I can't even get up here.
You have to let go because I can't even get up here!
I can't use the magnet!
Hey, I don't know where to go from here.
Where do we go from here?
We just... Oh!
Oh, it's a meat in the middle!
Okay, I'll go on the other side.
You stay there.
Alright, here we go.
Are you ready?
Three, two, one, go!
We did it.
Through sheer determination.
It says come!
This is a healthy marriage.
Look, it spells come!
Look, look, look, look!
I'm not looking.
I'm closing my eyes.
Look, look!
Keep disconnected!
We made it!
Yes!
That was good, Jiwa!
Yeah!
See, this is a healthy relationship.
A healthy marriage.
My turn to sit here.
I think we can finish the game.
No way!
There's no way!
I think we can finish the game.
Kumi, Kumi, there's two more chapters.
Kumi.
Hello, Kazu.
Focus.
Oh, pretty.
The Aurorae Aurealis.
At this time of day.
What are you saying?
The Aurorae Aurealis.
At this time of day.
At this hour.
Right in this very location.
The snow globe.
Wait, what was it again?
The what?
The Aurorae Aurealis.
Aurora?
Aurorae Aurealis.
Really?
How you forgot your whole speech.
It was the worst proposal in the history of the world.
Wait, I proposed to you here?
I thought you proposed here?
Yeah, I proposed here.
Look at the memories.
Who's the way you handled it?
Without trying to hide how scared you were.
It was brave.
I'm a brave boy.
Mama said I'm a brave boy.
Why do you keep talking?
Eww.
Bro, he ruined the moment.
You're making great progress.
He ruined the moment.
Are you ready?
Let's get going.
I hate seeing his disinfigured tongue in his mouth.
Oh, is the lights working?
Wow.
The lights working again.
Shake it.
They're still inside.
Dad, Dad, look.
Look at the snow globe.
You hear the screams in the snow globe.
Why haven't I ever seen this picture before?
Look, Dad.
That's when Daddy and Mommy were last happy before I was born.
Haha.
Aha.
Letter B's number two.
Dear Mom and Dad.
Isn't this exciting?
Yes, we're thrilled.
Good.
Now, how do you find your purpose in life?
Hm?
Through...
Wait for it...
Passion!
Oh, God.
We're going to have sex.
What?
Because you've lost your passion, Cody.
A passion that lights the path to your purpose in life.
Passion, path, purpose, passion.
You know, huh?
Uh, no.
Maybe he's talking about you wanting to be a gardener.
Yeah, it's about gardening.
God, Kumi.
You can't be moved here.
It was about gardening.
I'm going to rake your garden.
What?
And...
I never really seemed to appreciate what I did.
Oh, so now it's my fault.
You see, this is why we can't live together.
You see?
And what did she say?
Oh, my God.
God.
Spread the seeds!
Who said I had zero risk?
Come on.
Even though I stole that from Chad.
I have garden riz.
Oh my god, it's my garden!
I told you I'm going to rake the garden!
The actual garden.
Oh yeah, but everything still looks... beautiful.
And all thanks to my painstaking groundwork, I might add.
Oh, really?
Painstaking groundwork, huh?
Look at this!
Come on!
Cousin, did you want to trade in the blanket with me?
Yeah!
Use your head!
And you will understand soon enough!
My head?
Yeah!
Woah!
Eww!
What the fuck?
Oh, that's fucking gross!
No!
Support God Passion!
Wait, what is that?
I think it's a weed killer.
Alright, we're calling here, right?
That was...
We can finish this next week.
There's still three more chapters.
You know, I'm happy to end it here.
Cause I ended up with my nice garden Riz.
Say ah.
What the fuck?!
No!
Say ah!
Noooo!
Ahhhh!
Say ahh!
Noooo!
Get away from me!
Say ah!
What the fuck is that?
Noo!
Stop!
What is that?
Say ahh.
I don't want to.
I don't want to!
I don't wanna!
Oh my god!
We'll finish this next week.
Oh my god, what a journey.
I feel like I aged so much.
Because we have a very loving relationship.
Every second spent with you is like...
is like a miracle.
Why do you keep saying these?
What do you mean?
Why?
I'm rising!
Is it working?
Is it?
Alright.
Are you gonna be taking a nap or are you gonna play...
What are you gonna play?
TFT?
I think I might log on Minecraft a little.
Minecraft?
See what's going on and then TFT.
Alright.
Have fun Minecrafting!
Have fun!
Maybe I'll take a nap.
Alright, I'll see you later then.
Alright, I'll message you.
Alright, bye bye!
Bye bye.
Woah!
You know it's love when your wife spits at you.
Alright, I'll see you later.
Bye bye.
Oh my god.
What a journey today, chat.
What a fucking journey.
Three more chapters left.
Woah!
Ah, I'm tired.
Oh yeah.
I know that I updates, updates, updates.
Apparently Challenger Circuit has been delayed.
There was an update regarding Challenger Circuit.
So, most likely I might take Saturday as a rest day.
So, uh...
Saturday might be a rest day then.
Because I decided to use it as a day to just rest up a little bit and recoup some energy.
So, that's gonna be delayed.
It's delayed to like April?
I think?
April 6th.
Yeah.
It's gonna be delayed to April 6th.
They're moving around the schedule to fit the other tournament that got delayed.
So there's a lot of stuff that's being moved around.
So that's why... that's why...
That shit is... that got moved.
Um...
And... uh...
What else?
Uh...
Uh... Next week, I know I said I wanted to play Dead Rising next week.
To start Dead Rising playthrough.
But then I remembered Dead Rising is majority escort missions.
And then like I already went through a lot of escort missions with Resident Evil.
So...
So I decided...
I decided that we're gonna play a different game.
We're gonna start a different game.
Next week.
Because I want a little break from doing escort missions.
So those are the updates for today.
I'm gonna call it here.
Um... Because I do have a lot of behind the scenes to work on.
As well as preparing for tomorrow's stream.
So I... unfortunately there will be no disaster on the chat reading.
But thank you all for coming.
I hope you guys enjoyed part two of It Takes Two.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Pause to check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!